okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel welcome to
episode episode i think eight of the
pregame
it might it might be nine i forget
i forgot to look before the show um
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys if you've watched two
or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef like real beef
i'm like super tough so
yeah real real beef
okay just so you guys know rules of the
stream no insulting guests no insulting
appearance anything like that we attack
ideas we don't attack people second
thing we have a stream sponsor so our
stream sponsor is cooking with chris he
offers completely custom meal plans that
you that allow you to eat delicious
foods while being your healthiest self
the link to that is in the description
if you get one you literally directly
support the stream and you support the
channel and i bought this myself so i'm
not advocating something i don't like
use i'm down like 10 pounds in a month
i'm like i'm having a skinny summer you
know what i mean
okay um so the topic today
we're gonna be talking about
does body count matter
and whose fault is it if you get knocked
up
so before i start i'd love for you guys
to introduce your names your age your
relationship status and where people can
find you
hey everyone um so i'm amy spot the
proper way amy
um i am 27 years old i am a single girl
who is dating
casually ding you know how it is
and um you can find me on
instagram at amyrduffy
a-m-y-r-d-u-fy or tik-tok at amy and
beyond what's up tim uh my name is kit
i'm 27 i am single currently dating and
you can find me at on instagram kit
underscore is underscore me and i have
my own youtube channel which you can
check out which is stay slick with kit
okay
so
to start we're going to talk about
body count and we can go around everyone
say their body count
[Applause]
yeah because it got to a point where i'm
like if people ask me i have to be like
hold on i'm like so now i just have a
list and i just count through the list
oh wow oh wow so i was i was ready to be
like i'll get the list off of my number
on the internet yes oh wow no shame in
this game baby yeah sure go get it
i'm like dead serious yeah i get it i
have a list but i think i stopped adding
to the list a few years ago
i was like i don't know if this is good
for me anymore
do you have a list
no no no
[Music]
however i think i've been highly
influenced by a lot of girls on tick
tock i see that some of them have got
like flash cards and like an excel
spreadsheet okay i really appreciate the
enthusiasm i just have a list because
that's it i don't know off the top of my
head my number so i have a list
and just in case i'm like oh i'd forget
them which i won't do and i've never
forgotten any of them but where is it
it's in here somewhere it's in here
somewhere
why are you finding that
what's your question
what was my question oh i said
well it was a joke question until but if
you want you can
you can put your body count on the
internet okay it
the list oh wow and some of them have
got brackets like boyfriend dating okay
um one guy
he's got what do you have for god just
that's that's his oh okay description
for watching this well done
tom from fanbrick shout out
like
well my body count is ambiguous in that
there's a threesome in there that i
don't really count because it was really
poor it was really bad and i'm like
so hold on let's give it one two three
we're gonna we're gonna count one two
three hey what's your body count
i uh lady number two oh like no
i'll tell you single digits okay
but i don't okay if you had to guess
mine would you guess
based on our last conversation i don't
know what you're talking about um
i would say like 50.
interesting
so we've got 33 or if you count the
threesome 35 i don't count the
threesomes so i'm like 33 33 33
and the gentleman never tells
[Music]
i'll give you a rain okay i'll tell you
what all right is it are you less than
three
digits yeah yeah i'm less than three
digits okay yeah okay less than 50.
moving on
okay so the question i have today is
does do you guys think body count
matters in the person that you date uh
person that i date yeah
uh and in general so i would say
no if i'm not taking her seriously
doesn't matter okay if i'm taking her
seriously
it's
i'm not gonna say it's negligible
it doesn't it's not the deciding factor
but it is something that i think
i would think about okay honest okay
what about you
i um
for me personally it actually doesn't
matter because i if people don't want to
tell me i'm like cool it's not it's your
past it's your business like
um
but i've genuinely had partners that
have had i i have slept with a guy who
slept with 350 women i'm and that's not
a joke are you afraid you're really
sorry
i'm a i'm a safe girl um but i've had
boyfriends but you can't you can't
protect yourself from like hpv like
you're gonna can't you know whatever
yeah
were you nervous no no because i make
sure that people i'm like hey okay okay
um i'm like at the end of the day you're
past your past and
i'm not very insecure i'm like in that
moment if you're sleeping with me you
may or may not be thinking about someone
else but
but i think i think it matters to other
people so i'm not i'm under no
dissolution that if i say to people like
i've slept with 33 guys then they'll be
like oh you're at home and i'm like okay
that's that's your opinion that's that's
cool cool that it doesn't really matter
to me to be honest
what about you does it matter
um
well
[Music]
i think that
it does and like it doesn't i think for
girls it matters more than for guys
yeah like i think it's a double standard
but i i think that it should be a double
standard actually
yeah yeah why do you think that because
it's easy for
women to get sex it's not easy for men
yeah and and we have like biological
predispositions and i don't think we can
like undo them
yeah
so um it's kind of like asking women not
to be attracted to success it's the same
way i think as asking like men not to be
kind of disgusted by a high body count
it's like natural because they wanted to
ensure paternity historically very true
so
part of my i did psychology at uni yeah
and part of my degree was a module
called the psychology of attractiveness
and the entire basis was sex and
relationships yeah and it says that
that's it biologically and you see in
the animal kingdom
that men will go for quantity women will
go for quality yeah yeah so if you've
got a high body count men are like
surely not all of these men are high
quality men yeah but that is discounting
evolution and discounting
sexual pleasure like
i don't sleep with men a lot of the time
because they're good guys i sleep with
men because i'm like i want to get laid
yeah and
actually to be fair i'm like
trying to cut back back on that but
um yeah i get that i get that a lot of
guys are like even though they happily
sleep with like a lot of people mm-hmm
and it's because yeah it's also like
lineage and yeah evolution well it's
like we can't just just just because
it's not like practical in today's day
because it's really unpractical when you
think about it because of the evolution
of birth control you know i'm saying
like you know and i think most guys like
want wives right like they want to get
married at some point and stuff
and i think
um
now the average age of first marriage is
27 where like they used to marry and
it's 31 in the uk actually it's like
higher yeah for women so i think you
know men would almost like a lot of
times like to not care but i don't think
you can undo their like biology
yeah i was gonna say like it's not like
it wouldn't be a deciding factor i don't
think depends how far in i was in terms
of like how far along we were yeah but
if i'm gonna sit here and pretend that
it doesn't like if i met a girl and she
was like oh she slept with like a
hundred guys
i'm not gonna pretend that wouldn't
at least impact oh is she like
girlfriend wifey material yeah because
obviously like you said like guys
the kind of woman that guys going to
take seriously is the kind of woman who
is sexually selective
and if a girl comes across to a guy that
she's not that selective then it just
makes him think i don't know there's
like there's like an
instinctual kind of thing that's like
you don't trust her judgment yeah yeah
well you don't trust her past judgment
yeah okay
however so full disclaimer i've been in
a host season and casual for the past
year because
i have been
really codependent i was for
all my sexual life i was very
codependent very exclusive
i only slept with like one person at a
time and then i got to a point where i
was like so life is not black and white
so i was either like why i'm single and
i'm not dating i'm not sleeping with
anyone or i'm looking for a relationship
and i was like wait there's this middle
ground intersection that is like oh
casual dating or casual sex and i was
like right as long as i'm being honest
i'm feeling respected i'm not lying to
anyone
and then it got to a point where it was
like
because men knew that other men were
interested in me they were like well
wait a minute she's desirable and i was
like oh okay
and then you kind of become it becomes
quite powerful it almost felt like
like i say
well i think i think men are more
competitive right so yeah
so um
i
i have jokingly had like a roster
because i'm like right all these men
that i've been casually seeing have told
me you're not gonna be my girlfriend
don't get attached i'm like okay cool so
what i'll do is i'll make sure do you
not get attached actually um
uh well
i'm yeah i'm cognizant enough to be
respectful and to know that if you tell
me i'm not gonna change your mind i'm
not gonna change you yeah
um so i'm like okay so i'll i'll okay
i'll make sure then that i'm dating
other people so if one of you ends it or
pisses me off or isn't available or you
know i'll just sort of spread through
the cycle so it's almost like you have
more as almost like a defense mechanism
so you don't get your feelings hurt yeah
like my attachment i don't know what my
attachment style is but it's probably
like very anxious
but
if i then i'm i'm a really open book i
don't lie to anyone i'm very much like
okay well if i'm dating you i'm also
dating other people but all of these
guys who have told me outright amy
you're not gonna be my girlfriend i'm
not gonna be serious about you don't get
feelings of me i'm like okay so to make
sure i'm respecting what you've said i'm
dating other people
to not get feelings to not get right
they get really upset about it yeah they
get really like the ego situation and
i'm like
but i'm confused i'm confused by that
like but they still don't want to date
you
they want to date me but they don't be
serious no like like an actual boyfriend
girlfriend yeah they still don't want
that they
they
like the it's more like they like the
idea of me but not the reality or you
know there's something that's just not
quite there and i'm like that's fine we
can have fun but i'm going to have fun
with other people yeah i can benefit
from you i think that like we're kind of
going against our biology when we try to
do that oh probably yeah well i don't
want kids so that really
like
it really [ __ ] people up sorry if i'm
not allowed to like because but um it
really [ __ ] like a lot of men are like
you're wrong and i'm like
no i i don't want kids and that's really
anti like biology and evolution i'm like
no i don't i don't well at least for now
i don't want you yeah what makes you if
you were infertile tomorrow would that
like make you sad or would you not care
no i wouldn't care at this point in my
life
yeah because i'd be like well if i want
kids there's a lot of ways to get kids
um but i think
i am at a point where i'm like i am
still baby i i honestly feel like i only
started living last year 26. and i want
to be selfish i want to be financially
secure
and i genuinely can't envision being
ready because if i ever had kids i'd
want to be 100 about them and i can't
envisage it like
there was a meme and it was like
everyone talks about freezing your eggs
i would love if we could have the baby
and freeze the baby that's it i will
freeze i'll have a baby i'll freeze the
baby i'll snap back into shape yeah live
my life yeah that would be great
do you like do you see your life because
i always think it's
sad kind of when like women don't want
kids
because yeah because like can you
imagine being like 50 and like by
yourself
but a lot of people
and at this point i was like at this
point in my life i'm like the only
reason i would have kids is so that
someone could look after me or i
wouldn't be lonely and that's a real
[ __ ] up reason to have kids
you know i don't think so i would love
to have so i think i'm lucky that a lot
of my best friends
are
gay men lesbian women or very much in
the same mindset and we're all like
there's nothing to stop you from being
eight-year-old either single or married
child child free by choice people just
living your life all in a house together
and i was like that sounds pretty elite
because then you're not lonely so well
then um my other question how much
you know when you turn 65 you need 2.5
million to retire
so so if you don't have like two incomes
like get married and like start a family
a lot of times like women end up
homeless well get married yes okay so
what you want to get married i want to
get married well
but even as a woman that's a real point
of contention because we get married
and you still kind of become that's a
lot of like i wouldn't i wouldn't i'm
a lot ah there's a lot of context here
about my family history so i grew up
i've got
six i'm a from one of six we grew up in
poverty my dad is a piece of [ __ ] um and
so my mom was actually the one who was
like she's had six kids all the same dad
and she was like do not have kids none
of you have kids she was like don't do
it don't do it
and i was like do you think that's out
of sort of like a fear mentality i think
she's got a lot of guilt yeah she's got
a lot of guilt where um she hasn't been
able to provide the way she wants to
provide yeah she's like i should be able
to
help you with a mortgage help with the
marriage and we're like you essentially
solely raised six kids
um
like we were all like at the point of
view where we're like hey it's our job
to look after you now like we turned 18
it's our job to retire you it's our job
to look after you she's got a lot of
guilt and she's and i think it's more
that because of her guilt because of our
care for her that i'm like do you know
what if you don't want to if you don't
want to ask to have kids i won't have
kids but i also i'm like
i'm too selfish at the moment and
selfish is a bad thing i'm too much like
if i ever never say never if i ever had
kids i'd want to be like i am happy to
commit all of my time i'm having to
sacrifice i'm happy to be like
financially you know you know what's
interesting they say that women around
like in their 30s all the ones that say
they don't want kids like start running
to a man i think apparently yeah your
biological apparently like your hormones
yeah like hey time as well yeah
but like i would very happily adopt i i
was training as a social worker for a
little while um and even that like
that is like um
you know there's a lot of if you want a
family you can have a family you don't
necessarily have to have your own kids
yeah but it's not really practical for
the average person i don't know how much
money you make um not a lot no
so if you want to do like freeze your
eggs and have kids like that that's a
good and also adoption isn't cheap you
probably need like 20 grand to do that
like my parents adopted three kids
so it's actually um yeah it's not an
easy process no no yeah so for the
average person it's not really like it's
because if you want it bad well
pregnancy isn't having a family haven't
that's it it's not cheap it's not easy
but pregnancy like it's definitely
cheaper than both of those options
if you want a family bad enough yeah
finances and that's that's the reason
that like i can't have a family because
i'm like
financially
like that's i'm like no but if i wanted
it enough like i'd make it happen i
don't prioritize it do you ever um
so going back to like the body count
thing it doesn't matter to you do you
judge men if they care about it
like do you think they have a right to
want what they want
um
i so i'm yeah opinionated but
non-judgmental so i'm like you know just
because i won't feel the same way as i
do
i'm like i understand why someone's
point of view is their point of view
like it doesn't mean that i don't feel
[ __ ] about it like if a guy a guy once
was like i said to him i was like oh
i've done casual dating i've done casual
sex and he's like that's really
unattractive and what hurt me most is
that i was like well you didn't give me
a chance to say
like
what i am now like you've judged me on
like
yeah but we judge a man on their past
all the time so if a guy said i was
unemployed for the last three years we
would probably judge him
yeah
and then she was just like oh do you
know what like does it really matter is
this gonna matter am i gonna cry about
this in two years time who who is this
man right yeah i mean a guy that you're
not committed to who cares i i
understand like his opinion doesn't mean
i literally had a single conversation
with as well and he was like it's not
attractive to me that you've done casual
dating casual sex he was like have you
ever had a one night stand i was like
yeah i have and he was like that's
really unattractive and blocked me and i
was just at first like my ego my
self-esteem was a bit like what the [ __ ]
and then i was like okay but you've told
me that you go on a lot of dates and a
lot right
but it's a double standard oh yeah yeah
yeah so i i i do think like men have the
right to judge us for that and i don't
think like
women
we could say we judge men for it but
it's just not true like women women it's
um i mean you probably know a psychology
pre-selection
yeah so if a man gets a lot of women
like historically he he would have been
able to like take care of a lot of women
so it's attractive to us
and we can't undo our biology right we
are how we are even if it's unpractical
in this day this is like animal the
kingdom um which is really funny um so
you've got like in the animal kingdom
the lions the male lions you've got the
big mane it's the male peacock and
there's their liar birds
it's the males who show off all of their
uh vocals it's uh there's a bird i can't
remember it's like a little robin but
it's the men and they literally like
create a nest and the woman so a lot of
it is the female selection yes yes um
and i think in humans it's become a bit
like it's it's ah there's there's no
black or whites
in humans i think it's the same thing
the only difference is that how we show
our worth as males is
you know if we take
the vantage point is that we know that
women are attracted to successful men
you go oh look at my house look at my
car yeah
the lifestyle that i'm living that is
all that's all the same as peacocking
basically for for guys i would say
yeah yeah
but success is also very subjective and
it also depends on what it's not
subjective
i don't know because your income is like
very very data driven but i would rather
have a man that knows about the ego and
has been through therapy and is like
really healthy than a man that's like so
i've dated a guy would you have you
dated have you dated a broke guy yeah
yeah yeah
why aren't you with them
um oh because of that what were you
talking about before the show
you broke up with him why
um
oh because
ambition not his money his ambition yeah
ambition and his inability to believe in
himself and make what
oh
like a guy that had a lot of money but
like didn't didn't do much so i i
understand what you're saying but we
can't we can't act like money is nothing
no yeah i'd rather make my own money you
know neo's misindependent like yeah she
won't let like she she wants amanda yeah
i am so ferociously like i am gonna have
my own mortgage i'm gonna have my own
like i'm gonna be that [ __ ] that's like
i've secretly got money on the side so
if you want to leave me if you want to
cheer me i'll be good i could see that
that's such a fear mindset oh yeah yeah
that's so exciting because yeah do you
think decisions made out of fear or good
decisions
don't know
do i make good decisions i have a q i've
ever
have a question do you think
that the reason you don't care about
right now
how much a man makes is because you're
not looking to have kids right now
you're not looking to settle down but if
you were if you got to a point where
you're like look i want to have a couple
of kids and you know as the woman you're
the one who bears the children right
you're the one who has to take time off
work
so you're gonna need a man who can
provide for you if you're gonna have at
least a reasonable comfortable life to
have kids so do you think that the
reason that you don't care about having
kids right now or you don't care about
whether a guy is broke
is because you're not going to settle
down whereas if you did you would care
100 and that's why i like when i said
that if i had kids i'd want to be
financially responsible i want to be
um so 100
yeah like i agree with that because
being selfish means that i can be
self-sufficient
but yeah if i had kids and i'm a very
big
i care more about other people than
myself so i'm like if i've got me that's
good that's cool but if i'm having kids
and especially like if you're
yeah again my own history
my dad was a piece of [ __ ] and could not
finance you before i did all that kind
of stuff but um yeah like if if i was
gonna plan on having kids with a guy
i'd be like
yeah no like i need to know that you can
provide so yeah i would definitely make
a difference if i wanted to have kids
and if that was where i was at 100 yeah
so then if we can all agree that we
don't agree that most women want kids at
some point
yeah yeah so that means most women will
always care about how much a man will
make always
regardless how independent she is
regardless of where she sits on the
political spectrum whether she's
conservative or liberal whatever
if a woman wants to have kids with a man
and she wants to build a family she will
always care to some degree about how
much he can make
i think the only anomaly that i would
have to take not to is there are some
women who choose to have kids like on
their own who choose to like have and
they're like
do you think that's wise when again we
need 2.5 million to retire and i don't
know what it is here but it's the
average income for a woman is 25 000 in
the u.s i'm gonna be really awful here
and i'm going to be like i think that's
a bit selfish yeah i'm going to be
really awful okay no i agree
unless unless it's a woman who is like
i'm
very comfortable i know i can give a kid
two incomes worth
like you know single like my mom is
technically a single pirate like shout
out to her but that's it i've seen what
it's done to her it's literally ruined
her to be like i can't help you with a
mortgage i can't help you the marriage i
can't help you with xyz
and that's the reason that she is like
hey don't have kids because
okay
[Music]
issues today
um i don't know what it's been but let
me know if you guys can hear us okay
sorry yeah um testing testing okay okay
go again yeah uh oh good are we good
yeah i think i should be able to hear
you um
turn down the right gain i don't know
how to do that um
let me see audio processing
yeah i don't know sorry guys we are
we're gonna try to fix it later okay
i also have a question okay go ahead go
ahead and hopefully it's not bleeding i
can hear you now um
so a lot of times will say they want a
guy he doesn't have to have money but he
has to have ambition
i'm gonna be honest i think that's just
another way that's just another way of
saying you want a guy
who has the potential to earn money in
the future because you can if the guy's
like the most ambitious reader you're
like okay well that doesn't amount to
any financial benefits do you know what
i mean what do you think
i actually 100 degree because i'm always
like talking about ambition but yeah i'm
not i'm not gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna be
like obviously money doesn't my
happiness but it by security comfort
equality of life
um and so if someone is ambitious
ambition well actually yeah to be fair
go back to ambition success you know
what yeah it does
at the end of the day
no one's going to say no to more money
no one's going to say they don't want
more money
um
and it's not as important as
oh well we had a conversation about the
nice guy complex
but um you know being nice is important
but it's the bare minimum it's literally
like breathing it's important but it's a
bare minimum i think that women don't
actually like nice guys because then why
do we hate men
being nice is
what the [ __ ] does that do for me if
you're nice i'm like no i'm saying like
like you always hear women say men are
trash if they weren't sleeping with the
trash men why would they say that that
is true
then i'll trust you i don't so
but but like you think that why because
you've probably slept with some men that
are trash that aren't nice that's what
i'm saying i don't think
that i don't think women actually like
nice guys yeah i i don't think men are
well i'm pansexual so this makes a lot
more sense to people i'm pansexual um i
think
i don't i don't actually think men are
trash because i've got a lot of good men
in my life
but um
it's more that well this is but then i'm
like this is on me if i'm choosing to
engage and entertain yeah i if i choose
to engage and entertain in like men that
i and i'll say i'm like i don't feel
respected by you and i'm like then amy
you can walk away you can walk away if
you don't respect it it's on you if
you're breaking your own and hurt
yeah so i'm like i'm very wise and like
i'm
uh i can't say wise but i'm like
like i'm aware enough to be like this is
on you girl like you could you could
yeah oh i think i take a lot of
accountability i'm like yeah like no i
agree i always say like it's my own
fault if like i'm in a situation i
shouldn't be and i'm like it's my fault
yeah and well but like as but then as a
woman we'd like expect i've been
cheating so i've only been in love maybe
twice in my adult life and both those
men cheated on me
and i was like okay at the end of the
day cheating isn't right if you're not
happy you can leave and i was like
however
i do recognize that maybe i know one of
them was actually like a complete like
narcissistic psychopath he lied about
having cancer he told me he had a cancer
and he didn't and i was like you're
actually a bad person
but one of them was a really nice guy
who was really in love with me and he
cheated on me and i was like
i understand that it's because
i wasn't giving him enough i understand
i actually understand that there was
part of my i was partly responsible for
him being miserable
but
um
but he he's a good guy that did a bad
thing because he was like
he took responsibility he's a good guy
and he faked cancer no no no no no no no
another guy
the cancer faker was like i don't know
he was like he was gaslight 101 and i
okay i fell for it and i stayed with him
he cheated on me like relentlessly yeah
this other guy everyone was like
sometimes how do you have the time
but this other guy he was like
so in love with me
and so when he cheated on me it really
impacted a lot of people because people
like we don't know who you are right now
because you were really in love with amy
and you cheated on her
and i'm like i think he cheated on me
because i and i still think it really
stems from me because i wasn't able to
accept his love i wasn't able to and i
think he got to a point where he was
like
when am i going to be enough when am i
going to be able to prove to her that
why is he i don't understand like
you weren't accepting his love what does
that mean um i think it comes from like
like trauma like
like what do you mean by like accept
because when i hear i can accept his
love
i think i'm worthy of love you don't
think you're wrong you don't think
you're worthy of love so if people
compliment me i can't take compliments
and if people are like i really love you
i'm like you're confused you're wrong
i'm like because there's so many people
out there who are better than me yeah
why would you love me i'm like oh you're
you're because they're not perfect
either yeah like no one's perfect like
i've done a lot of therapy
yeah and they were literally like amy
because of my background they're like
love to you is very transactional from
what my history they're like love is
transactional it's very tumultuous it's
very like i think love is transactional
oh yeah i think like like everyone
brings value to even a friendship or
relationship like you're people
yeah most people aren't going to stay if
you're adding no value to their life but
then that depends on your self-worth so
the past year
a really good friend of mine you're just
like you're self-worth what does that
mean i don't get that so if if i believe
yeah you know what i'm a catch yeah i
believe that i promise it's like
confidence yeah okay self-assuredness
and recently i'm like i'm i'm not curing
cancer i'm not going to the moon if
anything it's that middle ground between
it's like being okay with being average
like most people are average i tell my i
tell people i'm like i'm average and
then like guys will be like but you're
not and it's like i'm not curing cancer
i'm not going to the moon yeah however
like it's that middle ground between
being self-assured and self-confident
and being humble when did average become
a bad thing yeah most people are average
no one of the quotes i love to like i
learned is like we can all believe that
we or someone we're dating yeah is one
in a million yeah but then you've got to
be like we're one of a million yeah well
over a million it's just i know i'm very
replaceable yeah yeah yeah it just it
almost sounds like even when you're
telling me about not wanting having kids
like it seems like it's almost like a
fear like a fear mindset a little bit
yeah yeah because i don't think it's
because i don't think i could provide
for a kid i don't think i could i don't
think i could match up so i'm like i'd
rather just not put a kid through that
yeah because i'm very compassionate no
i'd rather i'd be like
no
but um
yeah i'd rather like never say never
yeah
yeah i have a question for the ladies on
the panel yeah do you think you could
love a man unconditionally no
yeah i think if i'm being honest no
why do you say no no because if he
murdered somebody i would leave sass
okay yeah like i'd be out
oh no if you had bundied me oh no
that's a condition that's good point
do you do you think men can love women
unconditionally
i i think more so than women can but i
do think that if a girl was 500 pounds
the guy would be less attached to her he
would be less attached sexually yeah
yeah romantically yeah well you see all
these podcasts recently though like if
my wife gains weight like when she's
pregnant all that stuff but but men
don't leave yeah they don't most of them
stay and so i saw a thing recently like
and this comes back to
the like research that i did when i did
like my degree and it was like um
women again equality over quantity but
men will actually
tend to get to a point where they're
like oh [ __ ] i actually need to settle
down and actually so they actually won't
they will men will actually settle which
is a really unpopular opinion yeah
because they'll get to a point where
they're like oh [ __ ] you know what i've
been seeing it done it all everyone else
is settling down she'll do she works
with what i want do you think men settle
because they're more realistic and women
are unrealistic
so like like women we kind of lie to
each other well massive romantic as well
well and we and we lie to each other
like we'll say lizzo is hot when come on
like
you're laughing because you know exactly
what i'm saying i know yeah i know right
you you get more attention because
you're you're thin right oh 100 yeah
yeah pretty privileged is a real thing
the halo effect is a real thing right
right there's a reason i dress up for
tonight though there's a reason for some
reason yeah and which is which is all
good and well but like will we tell our
friend that
no no
you try and be a good person you're
trying to be supportive but
like the the facts speak for themselves
the technology speaks for itself like
yeah yeah are less attracted to a big
unless they've got like a kink for it
men let's attract to a bigger woman but
i think like we almost like lie to girls
and say don't settle don't settle but
like you have to settle on something
like yeah like you gotta i mean if
you're not perfect you can't expect the
person you date
i i
i don't believe
that there's such a thing as settling
and what i mean is this
like
as human beings we're quite
selfish we always choose what we feel is
the best option yeah
so if you choose someone
right
that was the best option you have
because that's not you settling that's
like saying oh i settled to go to
reading university instead of going to
oxford it's like well you didn't get an
offer from oxford so you're not settling
for reading you just didn't get you
didn't have the option that you wanted
so like i don't believe there's actually
a thing called setting because it sounds
like the people that went to a d3 school
in the u.s
i'm very familiar with this
so but again this comes from this whole
like black and white thinking ideology
of like there's a right way there's
wrong way there's about real worse it's
like actually very few things in life
are right or wrong black white and when
you become comfortable with that middle
path that grey area
like there just is what there is
and so
like what do you mean with what
with any with everything and anything
there's a great there's a middle path
there's a gray yeah being comfortable
with this is what i prioritize or i
think is right yeah so i don't use the
word should anymore because there's a
lot of ideas of what you should be it's
like
compared to who where did that come from
and so i'm like there just is they're
just yeah so i just i need can i have an
example
um okay so i'm 27. i don't have a career
i get i
i was a very gifted kid and everyone was
like she's gonna go to cambridge she's
gonna um
she's gonna be a doctor she's gonna be a
lawyer i am [ __ ] none of those things i
graduated six years ago for my degree
and i am definitely untapped potential
and if i think about what i should be in
the eyes of others i'm a failure if they
if i think about why i am i am the
happiest i've ever been
and so it's like again well it's that
kind of success thing and it's like
and it's like well yeah i think i think
in comparison to the thief of joy
which is 100 like like because a lot of
times even in the manosphere we talk
about stuff like you can't really change
like we'll talk about like a guy being
short and how he can't get as many girls
but what are you gonna do change your
height or like a woman's age like what
am i gonna do get younger and i'm gonna
be i'm gonna be real so my last
boyfriend was
a short king and i was like it didn't
stop me from being in a relationship
with him but if i'm being honest i
wanted him to i wanted a total boyfriend
i wanted a toilet boyfriend and i know
that's toxic masculinity and i know
that's all is it toxic it's not it's
your biology
it's like it's not toxic and that's what
like we we call these things toxic that
just are and we try to say that but
they're toxic to men because then short
men are like i'm not i'm not good enough
yeah but like
you can't call it toxic when it's
biology it's just it's the same thing
with like
men being
turned off by fat girls yeah but so then
it is toxic to the individual
experiencing it so a fat girl is like i
feel unattractive i hate my life i'm not
worthy i'm not valuable yeah so a short
guy that's the benefit is my last
boyfriend he was actually very
comfortable he was like i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah but i was like i also have
like i that's it i love being made to
feel tiny so i did yeah i don't
intentionally date tall guys i dated him
he didn't like when i wore heels and i
was like respectfully that's a you
problem i'm gonna wear heels like if
you're comfortable enough you're
comfortable enough but i was like yeah
i'd be alive i said i didn't wish you
were taller and maybe so tiny i just
don't really going back to the toxic
thing i just i get i don't i don't think
it's toxic it just is it's like like
that's life and life has some fat life
has some facts that aren't pleasant yeah
and we can't if we just say oh it's
toxic like they shouldn't exist they do
exist well that's right and that's a
really healthy ego yeah i'm a big fan of
ego so if you're if you're secure that's
it my ex he was like i'm five foot six
yeah and he was like i literally don't
give a [ __ ] but he did give a [ __ ] when
i wore heels but there are some people
who are like well because he can't he
can't do anything about it so he might
as well just like get jacked and make
the most money he can and finally
actually they can they've got those uh
they've got those shoe fillers for guys
out there now if you need it you've got
some shuffling so if you're a guy if
you're under five nine just find
yourself some shoe fullers they get them
all the time which i feel like well i'm
six one so i'm like
like you're helping out the competition
what's going on
[Music]
okay i have a question right i get what
you mean about toxic yeah right like
things that come natural to us yeah even
if they're unpleasant truths yeah
doesn't mean we should label them toxic
what would you see
as toxic behavior and why would you
label that as toxic as opposed to some
of the things we've talked about toxic
uh gaslighting like making someone
question their reality okay i'd say
that's toxic
it's a form it's a form of manipulation
right yeah like manipulation like is
manipulation not part of
hasn't that been part of human history
throughout could you not argue that
trying to manipulate to get what you
want in life is actually part of the
human condition oh it absolutely is you
read the 48 laws of power i haven't
known
really oh that's a really big yeah it
talks about like the
tactics people have used over the course
of human history to like get to power
right yeah so that's so essentially
manipulation is almost part of our
biology
yeah probably so why is that toxic then
why is it i would say that behavior is
toxic
like one is just like a fact one's a
behavior
like women are not attracted to short
men that's just that just is yeah one's
a behavior and something you're doing
and you know just because like it
happens like
so has you know genocide yeah
like there are people there are power
you know you can power can be used for
good or evil not every form of
manipulation is bad so i guess the toxic
is
it's only toxic when there's a choice
involved
so you can't help who you're attracted
to yeah so you can't help being
attracted to tall guys yeah so that's
it's not toxic but you can choose
whether you want to manipulate someone
so that's toxic behavior yeah i mean
yeah i guess yeah you can choose
somewhere i don't have to think about
that more
that's not special but it's kind of like
i don't know there is
there's good and bad you know what i
mean like
you can there's manipulation
tactics that's really subjective in
itself like um i'm a very anti that's it
one i've had a relationship with like a
gaslighter who like pretended to have
cancer and genuinely ruined my life but
um
this is like to him he was in the right
and there's a poem okay this is so nerdy
but there's a poem and it's about
a um
a nazi who worked at bergen-belsen like
one of the concentration camps it's like
that's objectively a bad thing but he
came home and he read stories to his
children and he button sweets so to them
he's a good person and so it's like that
that subjectivity of like and so
gaslighters will literally think that
they're not bad and you're they're like
to everyone else and this is this really
relates to people who stay in abusive
relationships as well and i have stayed
in a lot of abusive or disrespectful
situations
where i'm like if a friend came to me
and went this is what i'm going through
i'd be like
are you are you confused you're being
disrespected well then when i'm in it
i'm like well it's because you're
attracted the the same traits that make
a man successful are the same traits
that make a man evil so you're attracted
to the same thing
so it's like disagreeableness that like
they tend to make more money but if
you're disagreeable you also could go to
prison
and then it's like so is it
if there are any good successful men out
there who are kind yeah hit me up here
well but the problem is you have to
compete for those guys so you know do
you know the stat where 80 if you ask 80
of women what they want in a man they'll
list 20 of men so the reason we hate man
is because we're all sleeping with the
same ones oh and i know there's a
there's oh i know there's that statistic
to be with like
oh i can't remember it i think you told
me it and it was really like the top
percentage of women one like women want
to sleep with the top percentage of men
but men are happy to sleep with
like but
that's what i think that's everyone
that's what it's called that's what
happened with the birth control pill so
the reason like actions have
consequences normally right so normally
you know um if we if we hooked up with
somebody we had a high chance of getting
pregnant so we would take a lot more
time to make sure that person like vet
that per that guy make sure he's
actually interested and he can actually
like help you with the family he'll be
there he'll stay around for the kid
nowadays we have birth control that
takes away the consequence so women can
sleep around with no consequences we
take away that like part of biology
that makes sense yeah so so now that
even a smaller percentage of men get
access to more and more women where the
rest of the men
get access to none
well arguably the consequence has just
shifted
that now that women obviously you know
sleep around whatever yeah you the
consequence of that is that it's
near
impossible to get coming from the men
that you truly desire
yeah that's true yeah that's a good
point yeah
yeah so do you do you feel like um
having a high body count as a girl has
consequences
um i think it does um i i think it does
and like even from experience i think
that's it some guys will be like this
turns me off but then i'm like okay then
you're you're yeah
i think compatibility is so important so
would you tell a young woman to sleep
around and like explore their sexuality
or would you tell them to keep your body
count as low as possible so you can get
the best quality husband
um
i would say what what is important to
you
and some people that's it some people
see some people sleep around for
validation and they'll be like don't do
that right don't do that like please
like don't do that like i have had
casual sex because i enjoy sex
that's the right long and short of it i
enjoy sex
um
female sexual liberation i'm all here
for it yeah um but i used to be very
codependent because it was all dependent
upon my self-worth was dependent upon
being desirable to a man and i got to a
point in like late 2020 where i was like
i don't want to do that anymore because
i've either been undervalued or
underappreciated and i ended up in
relationships where i thought the men
were my league
but they didn't respect me so then i
dated men who were under my league who
adored me and then i was like you're not
enough
well do you yeah do you think maybe they
were actually your league because like
you can't say that someone was your
league if they weren't able to commit to
you like your league is who you can get
to commit to you but then this comes to
the success and ambition and blah blah
blah and like right but remember men and
women are valued for different things
yeah so
i settled for men that were short and
broke i settled for men but they could
say like they settled for you with a
high body count but they could they
could say the same thing but they are
men that literally the men that i
settled for were men that literally were
like they look at me in the morning and
be like you're the most beautiful person
in the world and i was like no i'm not
you're correct i you i was like you
literally you expect too too little i
guess you simpson behavior i get you
different behavior
behavior yeah like i was gonna say i
think there is a i think there is a
middle yeah between um between
uh a girl getting a guy
because i get what you're saying yeah
like
for for girls your league isn't who you
can sleep with your league is who you
can get who can get to commit to you
but what i would say is that a lot of
girls date guys who could have committed
to them but because they've dated them
in a certain way they've put themselves
in the friends of benefit zone so now
that's not
on the table does that make sense so i
think there is like you know for sure
like there is like a you know like oh if
a guy's a nine and he's sleeping with a
girl who's quoting quite a five that
she's probably never gonna commit to her
right but it's possible that okay for
guys in eight who gets a lot of
attention he may sleep with a girl as an
a but if she
plays it wrong you might think oh she's
hot
like she's very attractive because she's
not girlfriend i think guys go down and
looks all the time i'm not like disney
but just sex yeah i'm not discounting
that but what i'm saying like as a girl
it's still what you can get to commit
because that's still you it's your it's
your choices yeah right it's true but i
think i think girls don't um
i think a lot of girls
do date guys who could have committed to
them it's just because the way they
dated them the guy was like well she's
not girlfriend material yeah and then
this does come back to body count
because i've had an experience where
recently a guy is like well i've not
dated anyone since you i get a bit
jealous when you tell me you want to end
things i'm like you've told me you're
not gonna commit to me you're not gonna
be serious about me i'm never gonna be
your girlfriend i'm like but you are
serious about me and to be fair body
count doesn't actually relate to our
situation
but
oh there's just so many like
really like intricate details and it's
not it's not necessarily like practical
in this day and age right because again
the average age of first marriage is 27.
like guys used to marry virgins and now
like guys don't even like want virgins
yeah but that's it it's that whole
whole black and white situation where a
guy you know
a lot of it's about ego and a lot of it
yeah a lot of it is about people's
self-worth and self-esteem
and i did have a really good point to
say and it's about um attractiveness
even that so i
used to go off of the ethos to a blind
person we all look the same so i gave a
lot of people chances and i used to go
on dates with anyone because i just
don't do that i'm like don't don't don't
do it this sounds so awful but like so i
did that i was like
give them
kiss people i give people my phone
number and be like i don't really want
to give you my phone but maybe if you're
showing me interest
and a guy so this is why i say
undervalued or underwhelmed yeah so that
was what i ended up in i used to be like
guys that i thought were like my level
my league would like not value me
and then guys that were who really
adored me loved me really valued me i
was like oh you're underwhelming i don't
think that you match up and that's why
i've been single single by choice for a
year and a half because i'm like i don't
want to get hurt i don't i don't want to
hurt anyone but i don't get hurt and i
was like i'm actually you're also you're
being alone you're also competing for a
small percentage of guys too that you're
probably attracted like you know that
only like 10 i don't even i don't know
the exact stat but
i've heard numbers from five to 15
percent of dating app swipes are i don't
use dating apps
because dating apps do tend to be a
black and white party in that you've
either got people on there who are like
i just want something casual nice not
nothing serious
um or you've got people who are like i'm
looking for a relationship so you've got
two types of processing you've got top
down or bottom up top down processing
and people who are like i want a
relationship ergo i'm looking for
someone who can
fill that criteria so when they go on
dates when they swipe they're like i'm
literally thinking about are you going
through relationship material
or
there's people like me i'm bottom up
where i'm like i'd rather just meet
someone and be like
where is this going to go let's live in
there now let's take it date by date
time by do you think that women it would
be better for women if we dated more
intentionally
because to me it's like if you could be
single you could be single let's say
you're single for five years you're in a
relationship for five years
like i would think that the girl would
probably be less like
heartbroken and have less trauma if she
was in a relationship for five years
because i mean assuming he's not
narcissist assuming assuming there's no
abuse narcissism like any of that stuff
because if you're just like dating
around like like i don't know like at
some point you're gonna get rejected by
guys that like don't call you back or
like like you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] like that happens all the time
better is subjective like eat pray love
is based on a real life story where
she's she's married she's successful
yeah she's like i'm actually not happy
i'm actually not like i'd like to circle
back with that lady yeah that turned out
yeah
and it's like
there are people who sometimes wake up
and go [ __ ] i'm not happy and i should
be happy i hate the concept of should
and so i'm i'm a really big advocate for
like difference do you do you think
happiness like comes and goes oh yeah
like like do you think you should just
leave a relation a relationship with
like kids and stuff if you're not happy
so i was gonna i was gonna say would you
here's a question would you sacrifice
happiness for fulfillment
yeah
would you because i think happened like
you said happiness can go up and down
yeah like it's an emotion right it comes
it's not happiness isn't a
permanent state that you can be in but
you can be content and fulfilled what
you have
but we just sacrifice happiness for
fulfillment
then it depends like for me
happiness
is probably
oh no to be fair happiness isn't
dependent on fulfillment but i'm always
over the obvious like we could die
tomorrow and if you're not happy and if
you're not like content if you're not if
you're not a whole
individual
then anything else that you like put
yourself into like
i don't know it's a really tough that's
it nothing is ever like that's it going
back that nothing is black and white
right or wrong better or worse
um
nothing's right or wrong but like it's
that gray area of like in some
situations i'd probably be like i'll
sacrifice happiness for like even when
you study or you you do a job if you do
a job you're interesting i think if you
ask men the same question most of them
would say yes i think women care a lot
more about being happy and men care a
lot more about being fulfilled well
that's like because i think i think it's
not about like you especially if you
have a family it's not about you anymore
like doesn't she leave does she leave a
husband and kids and eat pray love
uh she leaves her husband i have kids
my husband did a job yeah like i don't
know i think that's that's a bit selfish
you're leaving a commitment you made for
what to go like go to india but to be
selfish means that we're prioritizing
what everyone else wants compared to
what we want yeah but sometimes what you
want isn't right like emotions come and
go people leave that's it right and
wrong very subjective there's it's all
about that gray area walking the middle
path right and wrong to one person so
that's it genocide and racism to one
person is right
like
things to one person are correct and you
could argue to your blue in the face and
be like that's not correct and they
literally will be like like that's it
hitler hitler literally what is she it's
it's not even right
i think there's consequences and i i i'd
really like to circle back with that
later yeah
she made a book she made a lot of money
it might have worked out yeah yeah no
she made that because yeah so you know
what i mean maybe she did but i don't
think the average woman that makes that
decision it's going to end up well for
her no no not at all and that's why
you've got to be cognizant of
differences and privileges and
circumstances and things like that so
yeah the average woman could not be like
i'm not happy in my job or my marriage
or being a mum yeah because then you're
like well [ __ ]
finances your your marriage your family
like your kids and the average woman
could not do that
um but does it mean that she shouldn't
want to or she like it's just like ah
but then you get stuck
being like are you living for yourself
or are you living for others are you
living with expectations i think it's
okay
i think it's okay to live for others and
i'll give you an example okay yeah i
live a lot for my dad's approval like a
lot i care a lot what my dad thinks like
a lot and i do a lot of things not
because i want to but because he wants
me to and i don't mean like like i would
i'm doing this clearly because i love
this yeah he doesn't care about social
media but just in terms of like like my
last boyfriend my dad didn't like and
that really bothered me it bothered me a
lot because i love my dad and i think
like there's some things it's okay
it's almost a good thing to like put you
know values and like your commitments
and like your word above what makes you
happy at the time yeah i i was gonna say
i think the difference between people
today and people back in the day is that
we back in the day people all about
community yeah it was all about doing
what's best for the community it was all
about doing what's best for your family
whereas now
i think
i think back then we didn't have enough
individualism
that people were sacrificing a lot of
their happiness for their community but
now we've gone the other way where
there's so much individualism now yeah
that people are no longer contributing
or even care about their local community
or their family and their nuclear family
which is why people leave
et cetera et cetera so i i agree and
you know i'm my family nigerian and in
our culture like once you have kids it's
about them you do what's best for them
so
if you but you staying with your partner
is what's best for the kids and you can
make that work that's what you do until
they leave then you split up or whatever
i actually i always say people always
ask me if i'd stay with a cheater and i
always say no unless
there were kids
interesting why do you say that because
if they're kids it's not about me
how about you
i mean i've i've stayed with jesus i've
stayed with jesus and i know a lot of
that is actually based upon my
self-worth and being like you know xyz
and i'd love to say no i know i deserve
better and no no but yeah if there's
kids it's a whole different ballpark and
if you're it depends on how selfish
yourself because being selfish isn't a
bad thing because if you're like well
i'm living for others then when do you
live for you because
and it oh it really depends on like so a
lot of people love honor and pride you
don't think being selfish is a bad thing
so no no so you say you live for your
dad's approval my dad's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah that's a piece of [ __ ] my family
we are not close at all my mom literally
had been like me
and so i'm like if i'm not living for me
and enjoying my life i could be dead
tomorrow and if i knew that i lived for
everyone else i'm living for their
approval or my well-being
and my quality of life is dependent upon
how they feel towards me yeah and if
that's it it's not black and white it's
very much like
the people i love
know that i love them the people i love
i'm i'm very much a i want you to feel
loved i want you but then i'm like
i've done a lot of therapy and so
they're like hey amy you can only feel
good about yourself when you think
others feel good about you and they're
like that's really so your self-worth is
dependent upon the approval of others i
think that's normal
oh well if everyone hates you there's
probably a reason well
as far as i'm aware no one has ever
hated me but i've been so i stayed with
the cheetah because yeah i've stayed
with many teachers
and i
i've been in a relationship that was
the most toxic thing that i've ever
imagined that everyone in my life is
like we don't he still talks to me and i
still haven't we broke up three four
years ago we still have an open
communication path because i can't block
people because i'm like i feel really
bad if i block them even they're toxic
for me and they're worse i can't block
them
i can't i can't do it that's it i can't
do it and everyone is like amy like are
you are you confused this person was
awful to you disrespected you and you
still feel the need to be good for them
good for their approval
and i'm just like
ah because it makes me feel like a bad
person where black people like so so
going okay so going back to the next
next topic tonight okay
we're going to talk about women getting
pregnant first going okay so i i'm going
to give you my opinion and you can
comment on it i think it's
99.999 the woman's fault if she gets
pregnant why do you think that because
we are in control of sex
we
one there's a million forms of birth
control
two
you can you can
you get to pick who you sleep with yep
and three
there's condoms and four you can even
get an abortion
so i think if you get pregnant it's your
own fault so you said it's 99.9 women's
i think that men out here just shooting
up and random girls are dumb okay i
think you guys are stupid
so do you think so but but i would say
that the responsibility is mostly on the
woman rather than the guy
so i
i
don't disagree that culturally so
there is more power in the woman in
regards to getting pregnant
but to say that men are only responsible
for one percent of that i disagree
i would say
because it does take two to tango
because here's the thing right
it is true that most men would have sex
with anything yeah
but they're the small percentage of men
who maybe have a lot of options
wouldn't
they exercise
discipline especially if their time is
money right but even even if let's say
they wear a condom right what happened
to drake
how does it count it does count that
happens to really successful men all the
time oh no what i mean is like that's
not that's completely on her that's not
even one person but that's what i'm
saying like even if a guy wears a condom
a girl can take it
it's true yeah that's that's true that
like this is an exception that's that's
not his fault but i would i would say if
she got pregnant from that that's that's
not 99 her that's 100 her yeah that's
none of him yeah i'm saying if it was
oh yeah yeah
um
[ __ ] you drake
no but if um if a guy if a guy has
because if she chooses to have
unprotected sex with him yeah making
that choice but he's making it okay but
let's say she does who is the who is the
choice to take the plan b pill
who has honor who has the power to yeah
she does she that's why who has the
power to get an abortion
it is her yeah it's true does the man
have any say in that i agree so that's
why i say it's it's her own fault you
could you could okay let's say let's say
one you can track your cycle there's
only like five days
in a month or whatever that you're
really likely to get pregnant i know
what can happen outside of that yeah
okay but you can track your cycle
that doesn't work what can you do a
condom okay
if that doesn't work you can get a plan
b pill
if that doesn't work next time around
get an iud so if that doesn't work no no
no no i'm not done okay if that doesn't
work and you get pregnant you can go get
an abortion
the men have no say in this not
i know so so
that's why i said culturally so i don't
understand how these girls are saying oh
it just happened what do you mean it
just happened that i agree that's silly
like and he goes just like oh my gosh it
just happened she got pregnant like
you you played that part yeah here's my
question to you right so there's like
over 40 forms of birth control for women
yeah
if it were reversed there was over 40
forms of birth control for men yeah but
it was still obviously women who choose
who have sex with so i'm saying the
intersexual dynamics yeah yeah yeah
but in terms of culturally it is men who
has the birth control power not women
would that then change your position
with that who's responsible
and who's responsible
no because at the end of the day women
men have no say in abortion if you get a
girl pregnant and you're crying to her
and saying i don't want you to get that
abortion
there ain't [ __ ] there ain't [ __ ] you
can do you can't save that kid
and
so at the end of the day a woman can't
have a child that they don't want to
have
so i fully agree with that i feel like
i'm fully like that's my personal like
if i ever got pregnant so i am sexually
active i'm not on contraception but i
tell men straight away i'm like come in
me don't come on me and i'm like but i
know if that if that happens i'm like
well it's my responsibility to be like
girl you're what what are you doing in
these streets
we're having a long host season
responsible season but i am i have
that's why i tell you guys
you can get one std that ruins your life
i've already had chlamydia i got
familiar
don't do this to yourself
i'm not familiar being responsible i got
committee
you clearly did it like
it wouldn't have been that responsive i
was 18 it was the second guy i ever
slept with my life we were friends we
went x y zed and then i get that text
being like hey and i was like hey he's
like oh so um
i uh wear a condom
uh no okay
but that but that is what i learned
people don't know he didn't he didn't
come inside me either
okay but that doesn't mean you're being
responsible
but a lot of people if you don't know
the media is passed just through contact
they don't need to come inside you so
even if they've got come in here on
their hands
what okay reduce your odds i mean at
that point at that point i was a very
different human being but i'm like oh i
had to come back but you're not because
you're doing the same thing now
well no no because i make sure that
everyone i make sure that everyone also
how do you make them get tested and make
them crazy really we don't say clean
either so i was an ex sexual health
professional we don't say clean we say
std free because obviously the opposite
of clean is dirty and we don't we don't
um perpetuate that like stigma so i'll
say like
i literally will say to people and be
like hey i'll tell them i'm like i'm not
on contraception but i i get tested very
regularly wait wait you're not well
you're not on birth control
no
and that is because
i can't
and that is because it [ __ ] it it
[ __ ] up my hair [ __ ] up my body it
[ __ ] up everything you know what [ __ ]
up your body a baby
but
i'm responsible for that i'm responsible
for that what income no no but what i'm
saying is abortion but what i'm saying
is you know what else [ __ ] up your body
abortion yeah yeah in your mental health
this is what we're talking about it's
responsibility is that i'm like if that
happened so
i tell men and they're like oh pull out
do you want to use a condom like cool
like i'm like yeah i'd rather they did
but if i ever got pregnant i wouldn't be
like well it's your fault i'd be like no
this is okay but this is like point in
case where women are using abortion as a
form of birth control instead of
something that should be used in an
emergency oh no no so like fortunately
that's it i'm 27 i've like had a lot of
i've had i've had a lot of girls sick
yeah um but that's it i'm like yeah we
will either i'll tell men and so a lot
of men a lot of men that i sleep with
actually to be fair most of them are
like well i'm either not going to come
on you or i'm going to wear a condom or
i'm like you're just not going to finish
like okay okay we'll finish in a another
way
um and if a guy is like i'm still going
to try and finish beside you i'm like no
you're not because like i'll call you
daddy but i don't want to make you a
daddy like that's literally like
i will say that to men all the time
i just want to clarify some
understanding so right now you're in the
streets right yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
straight you're streaming you know
straight but even that is that that is a
judgment on women to be like hey casual
sex is not okay for women
i didn't say if it was okay for me what
what i'm what i'm what i'm judging you
for i'm gonna be honest yeah go for it
it's just it's just like this is so
irresponsible because if i'm
understanding it right okay
so so you're sleeping with these guys
you don't you don't
them i know i know very well okay okay
you date them you date them and you're
not on birth control you have them
finishing you no they don't finish me no
no no no no no no never you're not come
on no no no the opposite the opposite oh
oh
oh no no [ __ ] there's like oh my god
i was gonna correct her but i wanted to
see how far this would go oh god oh my
god no okay no no that's my bad oh my
god nope there's that here's the love
here's the honor if you can't come in
here come on her i tell men straight
away straight away i'm like do not
finish inside me and that's why i say
i'm like i will call you daddy do you
want to be a daddy they all go no people
let me just clarify
you're only you don't have the more
condoms though your only form of is pull
out oh no no like they can wear a condom
but then then it's on the guy that
they're like well i don't want to yeah
you get to pick so like like do you do
make them wear condoms i don't make them
if they don't want to okay but then i i
have the conversation with them i'm like
look you've got choices either you don't
finish you wear a condom okay or you
pull out but i'm well aware that if they
don't if they don't pull out in time i'm
like i'm just trying to recycle too yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um i get tested very regularly that's it
ex sexual health professional sexual
health is the one part of our health
that we are fully responsible for we are
fully responsible for getting tested we
are fully responsible for you i agree
i do think as an individual as a woman
if i was to get pregnant from my
reckless behavior i'd be like it's not
on you it's on me i have taken that risk
yeah and i was like i'll take that risk
but because i am very comfortable with
the idea of i know the washer's not nice
yeah i'm not here like if i get pregnant
i have an abortion yeah i'm like do you
know what if like you don't get in a car
thinking i'm going to be in a car
accident but you know full well every
time you get in a car or you get on a
plane
there is a low-key chance that this
could not end well for me it's just
interesting because whenever like i talk
to people about abortion they always um
make it seem like it's only used in like
chill but no not no that's not chill
that it's only used in cases of
emergencies and like like
all that stuff but and my feeling is
that it's more used as a form of birth
control today rather than and it's
usually because there's some form of
irresponsibility so rather than like the
exceptions so that is very so i was a
sexual health advisor for the largest
trust in the uk
the british pregnancy advisory service i
don't know the number one i don't know
every single person that i know that's
had an abortion
it was like just them being
irresponsible like it was literally just
them being like i don't know a single
person well i i've in my time in my
position i'd only spoken to one girl who
was like
oh yeah i need an abortion but i used to
know the be passed number but off by
heart it's something like oh 300 300 800
or 300 800 oh i mean i do it off by
heart but the first woman i ever spoke
to and assisted in abortion
she was a married woman
she had two kids her oldest son was
disabled
um she was like even my daughter that we
had was like an accident but a happy
accident and she was like she was
sobbing to me on the phone she was like
in her late 30s and she was like
something maybe say that's not really
like natural if we're like sobbing like
like if that's your reaction to it yeah
yeah no no no but then i was like you
don't need to explain yourself to me i
was like it's not my business i was like
it's not my business not my opinion i
was like you like you've clearly had
like a nice night with your husband your
family like you've got a lot of [ __ ]
going on i was like it's not my business
i was like if you want an abortion
abortion yeah but then i've also spoken
to some women who were like
really chill like hey i need an abortion
as if it's birth control yeah yeah and
they're like
honey like that's
just just go just go on proper birth
control you know you know my mom was in
a position where she like she like most
people would have advised her to get an
abortion because she was 17 and she got
pregnant
but um by my dad actually at the time
and they actually ended up like giving
up that kid for adoption and he like
he ended up being like a really
successful like sales software engineer
he just got married that's why i
actually have a really hard time with it
because i feel like if anyone was going
to get it it could have been my mom like
she was broke she was 17. so this is
very interesting um
i studied under professor roger ingram
if he's ever watching which he might not
be so i studied um psychology of sexual
health and we did um my personal project
was outcomes of teenage conception yeah
and it's proven all of the research and
you have to obviously look in the bias
all the research shows that it's more
harmful for the woman the better of that
child to have a child and give it up
than it is to have an uh an abortion
what do you what does that mean it's
more like so the woman for the rest of
her life will be like
did i make the right choice is my child
okay rather than being like i'm gonna
have an abortion and this is why
and so i think i think a lot of times
like again we're making it about us when
it's really it's not about you because
there's a kid in the picture yeah so you
can't you can't you can't you can't then
but then it's like why is that kid more
important than you
why i mean i think in my mom's case like
he grew up to like have a really great
life yeah yeah like and so it kind of
like rubs me the wrong way
i think i think that's like why it rubs
me wrong way a little bit when people
are like make it not a life because like
my brother grew up and like yeah did all
these like amazing yeah and there's
always going to be but this is why so uh
roger ingram he's a professor he's a
professor he's like the best in his
field
um he so he literally told everyone he
was like we don't use the term pro-life
right to be pro-life you would have to
be a vegetarian a vegan you won't step
on an amp but you would care about that
woman you're telling you i want an
abortion because i mean you're you're
either pro-choice or you're
anti-abortion you're not pro-life
because
i need you to clarify that so because
i step on ants yeah
that doesn't really make sense so that's
well then you're not pro-life because
that's our life that's that's not a
human life
so then you're pro-human life but then
if you're pro-human but like i think
it's like easily implied like like
everyone everyone you know you know okay
okay let me just let me just let me just
ask you do you do you think there's a
difference between a human life and an
aunt yeah i do but then it's still a
life it's right but i know but like
you're just kind of trying to get like a
gotcha question like oh it's a little
clearly everyone
yeah i want an abortion yeah
why is her life less important
because i don't think just because you
have a kid your life is over
i also think i also think the argument
is that she's in that situation
because of the decisions that she's made
whereas
the consequences happening to the child
which is the only innocent party
arguably does that make sense but again
it's like if it's a ball of cells but
also okay what if she's on contraception
and she's taking this like it has a
unique dna sequence yeah like a very
like you can see but then why is it
if she doesn't value it why is it
valuable to everyone else and then we go
on to adoption okay if these kids are
valuable why are we overrun in every
western community of like
children get that's it they get your so
you think the kids aren't valuable if
they're poor i think they're valuable
but they're clearly not being adopted by
people who are pro-life they're they are
there my parents are pro-life they
adopted three kids and you gave up one
but that's but that's just your personal
experience right there's a lot of people
that want to adopt like even now like
yeah it's but then
is that like the legal systems are
aren't don't make it easy yeah no so a
lot like there's
families that have been waiting for
years to adopt but like they want a baby
they don't want a kid that's been
waiting for years oh for sure that's i
mean i've seen like i've actually seen
the negative like consequences of
getting a kid that's too old it's really
hard to d like if you if you get them
past a certain age a lot of them come
with a lot of issues yeah like this is
it yeah professor
all of the right shows so i think i
ideally i think ideally like it would be
better if the kids were adopted earlier
rather than like growing up in foster
care that's not good for any kid yeah
but then they don't get a choice in that
they don't get a say when they're born
that's just a decision made for them by
being forced to be born and there's a
lot of people who
will joke and be like i didn't ask to be
born so i was suicidal for three years
and i was like i didn't have to be born
and my mom will say to me my mom is
quite unwell at the moment my mum will
say to me i wish i would she's like i
wish i bought you yeah that's really sad
yeah but i know she doesn't mean it i
know she loves me but she's like i have
so much guilt and she was a mum who
carried us to term who looked after us
and she's like i still feel like i can't
provide for you and i'm like no i get it
i understand that you would
not have a lot of guilt you wouldn't
have a lot of like responsibilities like
expo said
um but i'm not again it's like it's also
a difference i understand that for a lot
of people they're successful stories for
a lot of people um but for myself
individually yeah it's just very i'm
very pro-choice yeah it's it's not black
or white it's just like almost like we
focus on like the negative stories
rather than the positive like even when
me and you talking about this now like
your focus immediately is well there's
all these kids in foster care that can't
get adopted rather than like the story i
just told you of the three dot like
right you you know it's just weird how
like that that's your immediate focus
rather like there's both you know what i
mean i i i have a question just played
devil's advocate um do you do you think
there is any circumstance where it is
better for a human being not to be born
than to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it
oh that's really hot like let's talk
about ukraine right now
like oh i'll give it i'll give an even
better i'll give you i'll give you a
better example let's talk about slavery
would you say it was better for
a child slave to not be born
than to be born and go through slavery
but then potentially have the chance for
freedom depending oh
that's really hard that's uh it's very
subjective it's very like
because there are some people who go
through [ __ ]
and they're like um so statistically and
anthropology anthropology
the highest quality of life is seen in
less economically developed countries so
people in like uh nigeria and ethiopia
are actually happier than those of us in
western societies and they've got much
less
and it's because you know the little
things mean more to them so it's like
we look at them as quote unquote charity
they have more meaning in their lives we
look at them as like quote-unquote
charity cases and a lot of westernized
people are like oh africa is poor africa
is exposed but actually they're very
happy they're very happy with a lot less
than what we are and it's very
subjective it's very like
i do not have the
um
i do not have the power to determine
what makes a good life to anyone but
myself but i'm just i'm just asking the
question i'm gonna ask you as well like
do you is there any
is there any circumstance where you
believe that a life being unborn is
better than the life not being born so
a big thing i
love um
yes or no
um i i don't that's it i don't have a
black or white yes or no but a big thing
a big fact is so in i believe it's
sweden 100
of embryos screened for down syndrome
are aborted 100
because they believe an individual with
down syndrome
won't have a good quality of life
and i fully disagree i work a lot with
people with developmental disabilities
and so people are like oh so if you've
got and um i interviewed cambridge and
they said this is the evidence that if
you have if you're pregnant and you live
in a uh built-up area and uh carbon
emissions it means you're more likely to
have a child with autism and they said
okay discuss this with me and i went i'm
not gonna discuss it and they were like
okay why and i said okay so you're
telling me if i live here you want me to
argue about whether or not my child is
more or less like to have autism and i
just went it doesn't matter to me and
then why and i was like because if my
child has autism i don't care i thought
i will love my child regardless of how
it's born yeah yeah
i just don't understand how you can't
answer that question because it
nothing's black or white yes or no it
kind of is like you can either think of
an example or you can't
i can think of an example for pro and
example for con as in like can you
is there any example where you can think
of
that a life has so much suffering it was
better that life was never born in the
first place
yeah i could think that but then i can
think the opposite so you can have
something so then so i would then say so
the answer to your question then the
answer to the question originally is
yes as in you do believe that a life it
is better you do believe there's a
situation where it is better for a life
not to be born if its life was to entail
so much suffering
but then that is dependent upon my own
bias
you're asking for your opinion yeah yeah
ah like that's it you say slavery
obviously you'd be like i wouldn't want
anyone to go through slavery but then
there are people who go through slavery
who could be like well actually
this is my reality however xyz is good
about my life so in
spite of slavery
i've got a good quality of life like
it's so who am i to tell you that your
life isn't good like oh no we're just
not just asking for like okay yes or no
it's
is that can can you think of a situation
where in your opinion it was better
for that person not to be born than to
go through what they went through in
life
i can't well then i would say that out
if you can't then i would say the answer
that is no then you believe that no
matter what suffering that life may go
through you believe that it that human
being being born will always be better
than not being born
but no i don't because that's it
no i don't because that's it it's not
black or white it's not yes or no
everything is the middle part everything
and like not everything but
technically everything is the gray area
because
i can say for my opinion so that's it my
mom didn't want me to be born she's she
had a mental breakdown two years ago and
was like i wish i never had any any of
you and i'm there like my life is really
good and in her mind she's like your
life is [ __ ] right your projection is
[ __ ] and i'm like no helen like my life
is really good
and so
who am i to tell who am i to decide ah
so this is i think it's women i think i
think it's women a lot of times when you
have to admit something that kind of
goes against your belief system we try
to avoid the question and i think if you
if you said that like in essence like
you'd be admitting to something against
your belief no i think that's just
that's because it's the idea because we
have to definitely write it and we don't
have a song but something's like it's a
little grounded but it's a black or
white question
but um nothing is backwards so i did
yeah dialectical behavioral therapy and
it's also with dbt and it's all due with
no we don't have to be black or white
yeah everything is in the gray i don't
know i don't know what dbt is so like
his but his question is like really it's
really black or white if you can either
think about it for example
thinking
yeah just to say you have to be yes or
no black or white i might wait for this
for this question for this question like
it's either well i was gonna say when
when kit said like oh no and i went well
yeah no but then you expanded upon it
went well but i don't agree with that
part so i agree with some of the no yeah
and i agree with some of the yes yeah so
it's a bit like
it's it's not
i hear what you're saying i asked you
pearl do you think um there's any
situation you can think of whether it
was better for life not to be born than
to experience that
i mean like
i probably would have aborted hitler
that's probably the only one
i'm like pretty pro-life but like i
probably would have aborted now
like knowing what i know now
um but i mean without like
you can't possibly know so i would say
no
like i can't think of
an example other than hitler yeah
maybe or you know maybe like a couple
brutal murders like i watched true crime
like what's the difference between
murder and just execution really it's
just perspective i think
but then can we appreciate that that's
not a hard no
because you've got an exception that's a
gray area that's the venn diagram i was
just i was just trying to be funny i was
just i was just trying to be funny yeah
but
there's some truth in it because if
you're saying do you know what because
because in the case of abortion like you
don't know you're never gonna know no
you don't so so what i'm saying is like
i actually
i actually wouldn't abort like hitler
well i'd only abort him knowing what i
know now but that's not a real situation
right so like like and honestly like i
don't think we have the right to play
god
because that's what you're doing you're
playing god then do you believe that
that all depends on if you believe in
god that really i do yeah yeah that's
true
that's true
i'm gonna read some super chats um
um
i'm very sorry the the female guest is
not reasonable at all abortions are not
self-paid by the public tax dollars
allowing for someone else to address
that abortion without care or concern is
the very definition of irresponsibility
in the uk they are so i was a sexual
health advisor i worked for bpas i help
women um access abortions uh here in the
uk they are so that's probably a uh yeah
yeah yeah okay wait these these might be
towards you because my audience is more
like agreeing with me no that's
absolutely fine reproductive
responsibility or lack thereof is
clearly illustrated by many articles
such that of the university of
massachusetts medical school titled who
are these four american women who chose
abortion shows the reasons
again it's very u.s cons yeah it's very
u.s based whereas i am uk so i think
a lot of my background and research
that's it professor roger ingram and
professor claire hart if you look at
their work in the psychology of
attractiveness and relationships and
psychology of um sexual health and
reproduction that's where a lot of my
bias comes from so you know i
acknowledge my bias i acknowledge and i
acknowledge your difference like
obviously your experience your knowledge
um i'm not gonna argue with you i'm
gonna say yeah cool like yeah difference
i'm comfortable with it like okay the
the foster child who was forced to be
born because they weren't asked let's
turn that around maybe the fetus within
the womb wants to be born but the
selfish woman overvalues themselves over
the child and it beforehand
but then we can ask is it a selfish man
that wants to come inside you like that
there's a lot of i've been telling man
they should wrap this there's a lot
there's a lot of i'm saying like
but then and that's it it's really not
black and white because then we'll get
men who are like oh you're pregnant you
want an abortion but i want that kid and
then it's like well wait wait a minute
it's not yours do you think do you think
men should ever say an abortion
like
i'm gonna be real no no i'm gonna be
real no because it's not your body i
would then say
if men can't have a say in abortion
which i kind of lowkey agree with then
men should be able to opt out of
fatherhood responsibility in the eyes of
the law
do you agree with that i do agree with
that if a man didn't want to become a
father
and oh it's real oh
so for example so here's the thing no no
wait so so here's the thing right here's
the thing right i knock you up you get
pregnant i don't want the kid you want
the kid right
i am saying i should be able to go you
know what i want nothing to that kid and
you cannot legally take me to court for
any child support for any help
whatsoever right i have the option to
opt out of fatherhood do you agree with
that
i do and i think like that's it if if i
came to you and i went hey look
um if you do xyz i'm gonna get pregnant
and you went ahead with it no but then
there's still that's still technically
on me to be like if you went oh okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] you anyway and then i'd
be like well no amy like you need to
we do all need to prioritize our own
self-interest so i'm personally like
i'm quite responsible in the i'm like
you know what it's on me i'm i'm not
gonna drag anyone i'm not gonna like
it's on me to deal with my own [ __ ]
so i would personally be like yeah like
and especially when that's why a lot of
people choose single parenthood um
if someone gets you pregnant not
particularly though like because you can
go after a man's financial like i mean
girls are trying yeah they're trying to
get they're trying to get killed
i think they're trying to
i do think that's the minority that are
trying to like trap a man i'll be honest
i've had
two women in my life which i guess isn't
a lot but i've had two women try and
trap me before
and if they got pregnant by me i
wouldn't be able to opt out of
fatherhood or responsibility i mean i
wouldn't anyway but i'm just saying like
i what i'm trying to say is it
not that it happens a lot
like i'll be honest like yeah i'm an
actor like i'm doing well but i'm not a
superstar by any means but purely
because of where they perceive animal
what i can do and they were older as
well
they were like
well i know that if i trap this guy like
i i know who he can provide for me do
you know what i mean
and
i'll be honest that is actually a really
big reason why
i've been more selective
with who i get myself involved in
because i feel like i'm getting to that
point where the age of women that i'm
dating now
that's within the realm of their
consciousness
does that make sense it's so it's so
crazy like if you're saying that yeah
especially if you're dating older women
and to a point where they're like i need
security
i don't
so i'm not sure if you answered the
question do you think that's fair though
like so if a woman can't get oh no i
didn't i don't think it's fine so i
don't know i'm saying like do you think
they should legally he could say like
let's say he he gets you pregnant
he he can legally say look i want her to
get an abortion she has a choice to get
it she's not getting it no i want to opt
out of the financial responsibility
i know i think it's all on the woman i'm
like you you're seriously you agree you
agree yeah you're a grown woman at that
point that if you want the kid or you
don't want the kid respectfully [ __ ]
what the guy thinks and i know that oh
he's half of like there's a lot of
things that come into it but i'm but i'm
not like yeah i'm asking about the money
part you're okay so like he he pays
nothing oh yeah yeah
if i get pregnant and a man is like i
don't want anything to do with this kid
i'm not going to go back and be like oh
well you didn't wrap up you didn't i'll
be like no this is on me this is my
decision i'm going to own it and you and
i would not no no i'd be like okay as
far as i'm aware my kid doesn't have a
dad as far as i'm aware i i am the one
parent that's that's my personal like
thing yeah yeah i wouldn't do it and i i
personally think that women that do that
i'm like
i think it's more selfish to be like
well you want this kid this is this is
your
this is how your life is but no i'm
personally like if a guy got me pregnant
and was like i don't know so we agree
there yeah yeah something 100 i'd be
like i'd be like like you've got to own
your own [ __ ] at the end of the day
because yeah the only person you ever
have 100 in your life is yourself so
you've got to own your [ __ ] you've
got to back your boss but then you've
got like
we're not all victims we're not yeah and
so it's like so yeah so you agree that
it's it's the majority the woman's fault
if you get pregnant
like it's it's your own fault i think i
think fault is the wrong word i would
use but in terms of responsibility
responsibility responsibility of choice
responsibilities your choice so it's
your fault no no because
it's got negative connotations so
responsibility to your choice it's your
body and so
if you were like let's say you're in a
loving relationship yeah and you get
pregnant and the guy's like well i
really want to be a dad at that and you
really don't want to carry a baby to
term you really don't want to lose your
job you don't do this you then have to
decide and if he's like
if if he's like
well i'll leave you and i'll be full
betrayed you then have to decide okay do
i care more about him and our
relationship or do i care more about
myself and it's like
we have got
we've got autonomy we've got choice
we've got responsibility and i think
that we need to stop pretending that
women are like pathetic or need a man or
xyz it's like no baby back
need
yourself
yeah
we do we don't need them because they do
no because they're lesbians who do you
who do you call to get your car fixed a
man or a woman your toilet breaks down
who do you call so i i fix my own car i
can i can do it i'm most mechanics your
power your power supply who runs it who
runs the infrastructure of society men
or women oh at the moment obviously
because because of patriarchy
wait wait do i need a man no this is i'm
obsessed with being a woman in a
male-dominated industry i do all of my
own carpentry
right but but regardless of that like
you agree that men run the
infrastructure so therefore at the
moment yeah men run the world so they we
need men
yeah yeah on a wider scale yes a wider
scale on a personal scale no because you
don't need a man to provide for you
right you can earn all right wait but we
need men to run the industries that keep
us alive and well not necessarily no so
because i know female mechanics
engineers right
remember that's exception like those
industries are like 99 percent now yeah
but for now right so now do you and we
can change that
but do we do it but do we want to change
that some women do something how do you
know the difference between women
picking the industries they want to pick
and
trying to [ __ ] the patriarchy no no i'm
saying like like
how do you know the difference between
women picking the industries they want
to pick
so like i don't know a lot of girls that
want to be plumbers mechanics engineers
and all that stuff
right but you're the exception you're
not the rule i don't know how many
that's what i'm saying so so when you
say things like it's because i'm so
valid but you're still valid but i'm
saying when you say things like because
of the patriarchy that's why women are
in those fields how do you know it's the
patriarchy and not women choosing what
they want to choose well you don't and
that's all my business right yeah i know
but like why do you automatically assume
patriarchy i don't know automatically
assume it but that's why we need men
because of the patriarchy right because
they are the ones who at the moment
control most of the world that's what we
need how do you know women don't control
most of the world because they don't
pick the industries where they're like
in control it's not michael white it's
right that's like gray area
right right but i'm saying like could it
possibly just be like i don't think
there's anything stopping women from
getting a job today i don't think we
have anything i think it's easier for
women than men yeah like and
yeah that's that's it again it depends
what industry it depends what like i
think this whole like the concept of
sleeping away to the top
women will get smaller
oh yeah
but
then it's like oh she was and it's like
well actually we're not then saying
you didn't respect a woman's capability
qualifications and you know you actually
disrespected her and were like you're
only valuable for your sexual like well
i think i think it's because like women
do that
but yeah
right and they get like
i don't think kamala would be in the
position that she's in if she didn't
do it yeah yeah but then it's like
people who have issues and it breaks
back to body count it's like i feel very
powerful when i sleep with a lot of men
i feel very powerful because i'm like
i i feel like i've like frauded half of
them i'm like you think that i'm good i
was like i'm i'm nothing compared to
half these [ __ ] out here like i'm
um
but
then like only fans as well it's a real
dichotomous like people being like is it
female empowerment to make money off of
your body or is it disrespectful is it
and i'm very much a middle ground
honestly
i'm looking at people like choosing what
they want to choose but i just think
we're not honest with women about the
consequences so like even with body
cameras
who cares because i don't care about the
consequences i would happily i would
have a porno and be like people like do
you care if your family yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] about my family
that's totally fine like i'm i'm all for
empowering women to do what i want to do
like if you if you want to go start your
only fans go ahead i'm not going to stop
you
go crazy like get that back but but
what i do think we do is like lie to
younger women and tell them there's no
consequences for that stuff
and and so we'll say like oh do sleep
with whoever you want and men won't care
they shouldn't care but they do care but
uh it depends if you think it's a lie it
really it's really like it's not it's
not it's not if i think it's a lie it's
like i have these
99 male followers i listen to men talk
every day they do care and biologically
there's a reason they care yeah i mean i
do do they care less than they did 100
years ago sure sure yeah yeah i don't
think like most guys want to but
i think most guys don't want their [ __ ]
on only fans yeah but then we can talk
about okay like let's get real like
women couldn't vote women couldn't have
jobs right black people were seen as
literally inhumane right and so you know
if we took that
that mindset back to where we were then
black people weren't human mm-hmm and so
you would not be sat here with us
because you would not yeah you would not
yet i'm just a little confused what is
that like i just was
i'm just confused what did that have to
do with what we were talking about so
it's in relation to saying like we're
lying okay so then essentially the
people who went black people are people
they were liars back then okay
but this is this is what i'm saying it's
it's lying to women when we're saying
like statistically they're like for
example when you when you sleep with
more men you lose your ability to pair
bond so you have a harder time bonding
with your husband later on like the
person that you marry and there there's
a million studies that'll back this up
yeah people you sleep with the less
like you you have a higher probability
of being divorced yeah yeah so so saying
to women empower yourself and sleep with
whoever you i'm not i'm not saying women
should be prudent not everyone wants to
get married and not everyone wants to be
parabonded and not everyone and not
everyone is scared
no and that's that's fine and so but i
think we should give women all of the
information oh yeah so yeah so i'm
saying like if you don't want to be
married and you want to be like by
yourself if that's what you want to do
go go do it i'm don't but like don't
i think a lot of times girls follow this
advice and they're not they're not
giving all the information but yeah
we're also just assuming that every man
is going to be like
you're worthless oh i'm not i'm not
assuming every man but i think that like
majority okay
would you would you prefer a girl that
has slept with a hundred people or slept
with ten
especially for me ten yeah yeah and like
i think if you ask like yeah guys would
you prefer someone more pure or more
more of a hoe most guys are going to say
more pure yeah but then you see for a
relationship yeah but then you see who
and what people then you see who and
what people watch on social media or
porn or who they engage with and you're
like oh you're a hot celebrity or
someone with a lot of followers or
someone who is very desirable or someone
who is and that's it nothing is black
and white but the the one thing i'll say
about that is i i understand about the
whole desirable thing but guys don't
really
care
how much
a girl is desired by other men that
seems to be more of a
woman thing that they'll use
pre-selectors by other women does that
make sense so like you know
you said this example i'll be honest no
matter how many guys are looking and
thirsting over lizzo
i'm not going to be thirsting over her i
mean she's not what i would look for
whereas like you get someone like jonah
hill if he was just your average guy no
one would want him but because of who he
is and women fought over him a lot of
him as attractive because he's desirable
to other women does that make sense
yeah like 100 like i'm that's it i'm
unfortunately i'm i'm aware of the
reality i'm not like delusional um
but then i'm aware of the science but so
being that's it psychology has been my
life for the past like oh my god when i
started i started studying it
oh my god 12 years ago
um and so it's the understanding of why
its behavior has come become that way
and the anthropology and all of that
stuff so i come from more of a
scientific fact but then i'm like i
obviously know my bias i obviously know
xyz but yeah like i'm not gonna i'm not
delusional in the lizzo being a big
woman is not
attractive but then you know like yeah
it's so so would you agree that we
should give like like the advice if a
for a girl that wants to be married
would be to like sleep with as little
men as possible
if you want to get married to the
highest value guy you can
i'm not saying like be a prude i'm not
saying something no no yeah it's like
it's like you should want to marry a man
that wants you regardless but but you
don't think you don't think your choices
have consequences like no i think
there's a consequence right and so you
don't think we should be honest to the
next generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth a date but one guy will care and
one guy
but but do the guys you want care is the
question that's i think that's different
i think that the difference is the the
high quality guys that most other women
would want
he's more he's going to care about these
things whereas there'll be some guys who
don't care but it's likely that those
guys that don't care not the guys you
want but then quality again is
subjective like would you rather have
someone who just accepts you for who you
are and loves you for who you are and
your history because then porn stars get
married but the numbers porn stars okay
but here's the thing they need to other
porn stars though
but here's statistically actually not
correct because i get studied here's
here's the thing the numbers the numbers
don't lie and actions have consequences
right and so we could say oh it's
subjective like what is quality but like
when you it's supply and demand yeah
like what what guys and why do we need
to all fit into the majority why do we
like i'm very happy being an anomaly i'm
very happy being oh oh like and i and i
say and i say go if you want to be an
anomaly go do it if that's what makes me
happy i'm never going to tell someone
how to live their life but what i'm
saying is like why do we lie to younger
women instead of giving them all the
information
like why don't we say the younger woman
if you if you want the highest the guy
with the most options okay if you want
the highest quality guy you can attain
putting your starting and only fans is
not the best way to get there but then
it's like i don't understand like to me
like this is common sense and i feel
like we should agree on this and it's
almost like you like are looking for
that exception because you don't want to
like you don't want to because what
we're doing then is putting what he
wants and he desires and he values above
ourselves well because it's not always
about you
and that's that's what i'm saying is
that he gets to choose who he wants to
marry and if you want to we get to
choose who we want to marry no women
marry who they can no i don't think
that's that's true like women
they have to propose so we don't choose
we don't have to no not at all
but do you not think do you not think
would you agree that women decide who
have sex
yeah yeah
so would you not think that it is men
who decide
who gets married
because a woman can say no
or a woman can ask and a woman has the
ability to be like look if you're not
going to commit to me i'm going to walk
away no i know but men can also say no
to sex right but we understand that
culturally when it comes to having sex
it is women who decide get access
yeah but you women usually don't say no
to marriage either
the majority of women who are proposed
to accept
i don't yeah i don't know statistically
that was it and again it's because what
i mean is like you know you know that
when you stay from the first day of a
guy you know that he would have sex with
you straight away
so
nine times out of ten a guy is ready to
have sex before the woman that's why she
has the power to who has sex right
but also nine times out of ten it is the
woman who is ready for the commitment so
he decides who he commits to and i think
that's what pearl's saying saying that
when it comes to marriage i i think
here's the thing like
before any woman has sex with a guy
she has he has to qualify himself to her
before she accepts that intimacy right
so the same is true
that women have to qualify themselves to
men if they want relationship and
commitment
but then so this then falls back to the
patriarchy why is it that women are the
ones who are like i have to look good i
have to be hairless well why do the men
have to say oh i have to have a good job
i have to like a girl could be
unemployed a dude will still date her
but like men have to qualify themselves
to women too it's like like you're
trying to like take away the things that
men care about yeah and the things that
like the things that women and men care
about just are yeah well that's that's
why i'm very i'm i'm so frustrating in
that i'm very gray area i'm very so
that's it i've had men that are broke
men that uh object i'm gonna say
objectively not very good looking men
that are short men that actually bring
little to the table other than being
nice right and um but would you would
you prefer a man that like i would
prefer yeah i would 100 prefer a man
that brought me more offered me more but
it didn't stop me from dating other men
it didn't stop me right but then i think
i think i'm the anomaly in that but i'm
saying like you would still prefer the
man that had more just like the man
would still prefer the woman that had
had less guys yeah and i think like like
it just is i'm not saying i mean i mean
it's not like you know
like double standards just are yeah
i was gonna say as well do you know um
i think the difference is
there and this goes back to like what
you were saying earlier what we've all
said earlier is i understand the notion
of you know you said oh but you should
want someone who loves you for you
but we all acknowledged earlier earlier
that love isn't conditioned is not
unconditional like love is very or if we
say love at least who we choose is
definitely conditional and some like you
could meet a guy who you think oh he
rocks my world intimacy wise but if you
want to start having a family and he's
really not doing anything with his life
it's like you may really care about him
but you may not choose him over the next
guy who can do that for you does that
make sense yeah and then i think it also
depends upon like
i'm going to be real it really depends
upon your mental health your well-being
you're like so i settled for people who
treat me like [ __ ]
and if if someone outside when amy this
is what this guy is doing to me i'd be
like are you confused like leave him
like what the [ __ ]
um
and yeah like i fully like agree with
that i fully agree that like that's it's
just not a simple yes or no but so would
you would you would you then go back
because love is conditional would you go
back on your statement that like the man
shouldn't love you for you like it's
it's conditional based on the choices
yeah like that's it so yeah that makes
sense so so you would agree then to
younger women we should tell you them
that actions have consequences and going
on only fans might not be the best
action if you want a husband i think
well that's the reality is that yeah it
will it will have consequences yeah
because it will some men won't care some
men will care right you have to be okay
and you have to be responsible to be
like i know that if i'm not only fans
some men are going to be like you're
trash well and as long as you're okay
with that then and especially the men
you want just like like women that are
models who do they tend to date
oh hot models yeah yeah no no like like
rich men yeah yeah rich men
men with the option i mean look at i'm
not saying like all guys that's like the
halo effect as well like if you are good
looking you are deemed to be more worthy
well then like a bad looking person no
it's more for women like men it's more
their accomplishments like us we have a
lot more value in our looks
which we all we enjoy the benefits of
but that's well
and this is such an anti like feminist
thing but
i will sometimes i will i'm
i'm a feminist but
in this world i'm like if i can bat my
eyelashes and do the whole little cute
little ah i'm like no i will fully milk
yeah
people like but you're a feminist and
you shouldn't do that and i'm like look
if i need to get ahead in any way i can
if i need to
be better looking yeah to come across as
better i'm going to be real well if i
came here looking like trash i think
that i'd get a lot like more mean
like i'm gonna i'm gonna be real um
and yeah like no i totally like well i
think i think it's like we so it's
almost like like feminism they want
equality when it
it they almost only wanted to gray no no
i'm saying like we don't actually want
equality it's just equality when it
benefits us yeah so so here's the thing
because i think you're right if you're
going to call a spade a spade you you as
a woman you're gonna use
the advantages you have
of being a woman to get yourself ahead
right that's what you just said
yeah yeah
so
yeah
that's right so then
can we i'm just playing devil's advocate
here can we then get annoyed at men
who use the advantages that they have to
get ahead
yeah but oh that's it it's it's not all
like it depends on the situation the
circumstance i'm so frustrating that i'm
very much like every situation
you can't block i think it's just when
you have to answer a question that goes
against your belief system that's what
that's no but that's no so because i did
dbt i'm non-judgmental and i'm very much
non
you don't commit you sit on the fence
because nothing is black and white
nothing and it makes life a lot more
enjoyable to not be so
committed to a certain belief or a
certain way of thinking i'm very
open-minded i'm very i'm very happy to
be told
i'm very happy for someone to have a
different opinion and to argue it and
i'm very much like oh do you know what
i've changed so i used to be very yeah
anti-abortion this is what really
surprises people i was very
anti-abortion as a teenager right and
then i switched and i was very i was
actually i was a massive prude i was a
massive prude i was very judgmental on
girls who were promiscuous or xyz
and now i'm like the opposite
and i'm very open to it it's not really
like it's not really like judgmental i i
don't
i don't care what people do like i don't
i don't think who you sleep with says
who you are as a person like i don't
know i don't give it like you you want
to do that but i just what what i don't
like is acting like there's no
consequences for it no there are and
there is i'm telling young girls there's
no consequences because there are and
that would literally be a
a blank face lie because we know they're
right we know there are right and in in
an ideal world
yeah there wouldn't be but you've got to
be you've got to be a realist you've got
to be a realist and be like there are
consequences to certain men and if those
are the men that you're after then you
have to actually cater to what they want
right and right so yeah yeah yeah so we
agree yeah yeah in a realist way yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah like next question yeah no no but
like nobody is in a realist way like and
it's not something that i
am happy about or i want to accept it
because of who i am as a person i'm like
oh okay if a guy is like that's it your
body count matters or xyz matters then
i'd be like okay compatibility-wise
you're not for me and they always say
you know if you wanted to he would or to
one person this will matter but to
another person this won't matter but
being realistic being that's it being
the reality of how life is how the world
is how society is how
[ __ ] matters [ __ ] has consequences and
you just have to be okay with
being comfortable with the controversy
yeah i i agree with that yeah
so as long as women and i do think it's
a lot more on women i really do so long
as a woman is self-assured enough and
her self-worth is to be like so i've had
men say to me and be like
um
i've had men be like oh you're not
you're not like thick enough you're not
xyz or um i get told that i'm dramatic
or that i'm too opinionated or that i
get told i'm too much quite a lot
and it really impacts who i am as a
person but then all of my boyfriends so
i asked a bunch of them recently i was
like was i difficult to laugh and they
went no you're very easy to love
and they were like maybe difficult to be
with the times but i get a lot of guys
be like you're difficult you're too much
you talk too much and i'm like what i'm
hearing is that i'm abundant and you
can't handle me like i don't want it is
it possible because i get that too i'm a
chit chatter i love to talk but it's
just like it is too much sometimes who
cares you're not too much they're not
enough no i think sometimes it's too
much but it's okay like i'm not perfect
then that's like the whole we know
there's consequences but i don't think
it like like it's kind of a bad
mentality to say like oh like i'm i'm
enough like i'll never change like
sometimes you're not sometimes yeah
for other people you've got to have that
middle ground between being selfish or
confident and then being humble
and then ah that's it you you want to be
palatable and accepted but you also want
to be
confident and secure and i don't care if
other people accept me or not and it's
uh it's messy
it's messy yeah i'm gonna read some
super chats um okay so the next one
uh did i read this already i can't
remember
did i did i do that oh yeah
okay okay if i didn't already um
zentience you are you have been super
chatting a lot lately i thank you oh by
the way guys all donations go
and reinvesting it into the studio so i
just got a new camera and the broken
house i think i broke my mic i'm not
really sure like what's going on with
them we're having problems i might
send money um anyways
and i'm gonna get a new table i'm gonna
get a wooden one because it's like
better for sound so
um sentience i hope i said that right
but you allow the man to finish inside
you you even said you would stop it
under certain circumstances why not stop
it under all circumstances accepting
accepting responsibility is not
conditional either be responsible or not
oh i don't let my i don't let men finish
your side yeah
so that might have been i don't let men
finish a hundred dollars super chat
yeah i should i actually told us about
this
i don't even know what i kind of i
played a sound i don't really know
that's right i haven't actually figured
out how to use the soundboard yet but um
pro actions predict future behavior past
actions predict future behavior if a
woman is impaired bonding look it up
she's more likely to revert to being a
304 infidelity divorce and if she isn't
bonded to her mate what sense
what sense man is going to willing to
bet she will
is willing to bet that she will make
moral and sound decisions
so it's like she's saying like if you're
sleeping around now like then that like
um i think that's really reductionist um
so if you knew me
i was suicidal i tried to kill myself a
couple of times
um and so if you knew me who i was um
even a year ago no no actually not a
year ago a year ago was good but two
years ago i was very codependent i was
very i had very low self-worth i had and
so to be like your past actions
determine who you are no you've spoke
about self-awareness it's all about yeah
you can't say if a guy went to prison
three times for for
attempted battery he might do it again
oh no 100 i understand like you you can
say that you can't say that but to
reduce a woman to be like oh just
because so i was very codependent and so
the men i date now
would be like well based on your history
you want a relationship with me you're
gonna fall in love with me and i'm like
you are very confused i don't want that
at all right now i will because i'm very
different
so i've been i've been single by choice
for a year and a half like that's not a
bad thing it's okay to like fall in love
it's like a year and a half it's been a
year and a half and i've not yeah yeah
but but i'm i'm saying like can i see
your question
if you met a guy that you really liked
and you were considering him for a
relationship
and he told you that he had cheated in
every relationship previous to this
are you saying that would not at all
impact his desirability to you
for a boyfriend no i'm not saying that
i'm not again that's it it's not black
and white it's not one size fits all i
will i will keep saying so i'm going i'm
blue in the face it's not one size fits
all it's really not saying not saying
that it'd be like not saying it's the
deciding factor but like
would it not shift your opinion of him
potentially as a boyfriend or do you
think it that would not impact your view
of him at all no no being being
realistic yeah you would be being a
realist yeah in the same way so you'd
understand if a guy viewed like
basically sleeping around a lot the same
way but then we've got yeah yeah but
then we've got
um if you have like 500 days of summer
is one of my favorite films and she says
when you know you know and i've dated a
lot of guys who are like i'm never gonna
be relation i'm never gonna i was like
well you will you will meet someone at
some point in your life it's probably
inevitable i know that you will meet
someone that you're like i'm gonna
settle down i don't agree with when you
know you know i think that you make a
choice
and like that's it like i don't think
most people well yeah when you know that
it's the right choice but i'm saying i
don't think you'll ever know and i think
that's like a lot of like now fear today
and like dating today is people thinking
that they're just gonna they're just
gonna know but all you can do is make a
decision with the information that you
have but then yeah but then you'll know
that but like
and even nowadays like people are dating
like what a decade five years three
years before they decide to get married
do you think those people just knew if
they're dating three like
three years like i don't think they know
it's the one i don't believe in the one
but i think they know that they
especially and so it that research shows
that women will kind of um
look for that long term men will get to
a point where they're suddenly like oh
[ __ ] i kind of need to settle down now
ergo i'm gonna look right if she's here
and she fits in she'll do so men
actually technically end up settling and
they don't know why is it one why is it
settling it's no it's it's they just
made a choice they said okay yeah i'm
looking to like get married in this time
frame this girl fits everything i i i'm
looking for but she doesn't necessarily
fit everything they're looking for
that's why because people aren't perfect
so i don't i don't think it's really
settling if you say okay she doesn't
have everything like it's kind of like
do you know what she'll do yeah she'll i
think women could be better but she'll
do yeah but i think women like
probably could you know have a little
bit more he'll do yeah yeah i don't
think that's a bad thing because i'm not
perfect yeah i can't expect the guy to
be perfect
and so like
yeah like i just i don't like the word
settling it's not settling yeah i i i
agree because especially with like
romance and like novels and like films
and stuff you believe that there's this
idea of the one and i know and it's like
you actually don't you actually just
need to be okay with what is and what's
happening and be like will you want more
probably a lot of people in
relationships and marriages you can ask
someone to be like what do you love
about your partner what do you not love
what do you wish was different like even
i would not date a snorer and that is
and that's uh
if you don't have a driver's license and
you snore and people are like well
that's not made people's fault and i was
like i literally know that i would want
to kill you if both of those things
weren't a thing yeah but if i really
loved a guy then i'd be like well [ __ ]
it i don't care i don't know i say like
girls have all these standards until
they met the guy that makes them not
care but then it's like well do i do i
know or am i like yeah here's
i always say i'd be the type i swear to
god i'd get married in six months
because i feel like
there's risk there's risk regardless
i'd rather just do it and hope for the
best and if it doesn't i'll get divor
like but like i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go into something
like okay being afraid of divorce
whatever it happens i hope it doesn't
happen to me like do you think you would
be more afraid of divorce if you're a
man
oh yeah i absolutely would yeah
because mine gets screwed over so oh
actually no no i got
i'm in this situation i should be afraid
of tomorrow
i should be afraid of you yeah you
should actually yeah you should but nah
i mean i think like again there's risk
with everything like so you think if
you're if you're a man you would look at
marriage as openly as you do now
um
probably not probably not i have a
question do you think your dad if he was
in our generation would get married
today yes you think he did yeah he he
wants my brother to get married oh wow
no i mean my dad my parents are more
like traditional so oh that's like like
i don't know i think there's a lot of
legal issues and problems that like i'll
advocate for for matt like they're not
represented fairly in court like i don't
i don't think that you should be able to
take half a man's income just because
you had a kid together yeah i i think
i'll be i think the laws are only going
to change
in
not the next generation next generation
after because a lot of men are saying
they're not going to get married because
of it and i think because women still
want to get married they're going to
start advocating for those laws to
change yeah no probably i think that's
right what are you going to say just
quickly
piggybacking off of that i think a lot
of like yeah you're saying men don't
want to get married women do and there's
a lot there is a lot of dependency upon
like taking a man's name and like
getting a mortgage all that stuff but i
really want to know how do you feel
about like
dads giving their daughter away
oh i think it's a really cute tradition
i wish i would i tell my dad i was i
tell him he could pick out my husband
all the time he doesn't want to though
he says i've got i'm busy
oh okay
so for me it'd be nice if he's like no
i'm not going to pick your husband you
pick someone that you think is well
that's kind of what he does he's like
because if it goes wrong you'll blame me
i'm not being in charge of that i have
to meet your dad at some point if he's
ever in london you have to tell me oh no
and you know i know from that's it my
own bias and my like poor relation with
my dad i'm like i hate the idea of
belonging to a man and being given to a
man but i know that actually if i had a
good relationship with my dad i'd
probably be in your shoes i'd probably
yeah oh it's actually really sweet i
mean because you're i think like as
women i mean
we're attracted to shitty traits and we
can't really help it like i'm
freud we have a field day no like we
like [ __ ] we do i mean and i
understand like the science of why it's
like the dark triad traits like the same
trait yeah can you can you define the
dart track because i only discovered
this recently oh god i don't remember it
off the top of my head but it's like
like a guy that's aggressive right like
why do women stay with the men that like
beat them because the same men that like
are aggressive and like beat them can
also beat up someone else so it's the
same trait yeah right a guy
like a guy that's controlling right he
also can control the environment yep
yeah so it's i don't remember all of
them but it's like it's like the same
traits that make a guy like completely
like an awful like partner also make him
a really good one yeah so i have a
question for the ladies on the panel um
if you know that this is what you're
attracted to why do you think so many
women say they just want a nice guy
i don't think they realize that they
said yeah i was gonna so my next
question was do you think a lot of women
are unaware of what they're actually
attracted to yes
yes i really think it comes from
inexperience because
at the end of the day being nice is not
enough it's really not enough it's the
bare minimum it's like breathing it's
like i don't think being nice is
actually i'd admired to be honest like a
bit like condition like unconditional
kindness from a man i think is seen as
weakness because well it's because like
it's a guy that doesn't like because a
lot of times this is this is my
experience a lot of times guys will say
they're nice but they're not they're not
actually nice
they're not nice they're afraid to stand
up for themselves and they're they like
we don't like guys that put us on a
pedestal like why do we think we like
like guys that make fun of us a little
bit yeah because you're treating us like
we're human so if we say something dumb
and you call it like
you know yeah or they think they're nice
because they're like well i'm not raping
someone i'm not beating you up ergo i'm
nice and i'm like
i've never heard a guy say that
we've never heard a guy say that we
a personal experience but yeah no i
think when guys say they're nice they're
like i've given her everything i take
her here i do this i do this
i think it's a lot of guys that go above
and beyond for women but women don't
respect guys that give them everything
without making them earn it but then we
get in cell culture
and so it's like men who are like i'm
xyz it's like you're not though you're
not as good as you think you are you are
the best being nice is the better well i
think incels are kind of a result of
women not settling
and like like women saying i'd rather be
alone than have to settle instead of
like i don't know and then this goes
back to i actually think men are not i
actually think and this is i actually
think as much as i'm for female
empowerment and like i actually think
men end up settling more
and i think men actually end up
disappointing themselves more being like
if you asked a man write down your
perfect woman on paper and let's compare
it to the woman that you ended up with
i think that yeah i think a lot more
women are actually like i'd rather be
alone than settle but then it's like you
actually could be alone forever if
you're not willing to settle if you're
not
but you can but you can't you can but
then you'll be homeless yeah yeah most
women you need 2.5 million to retire
um
i in regards to men settling i think
that i think men just don't have a lot
on their list
for women i think they're just a one
honestly i think
i think the majority of men in terms of
long term just want a woman who's warm
kind and peaceful
um and as if she's there with a low body
count
[Music]
well yeah ideally i think ideally but i
think even if she i think that's i think
that is a preference
but i think i think the difference is
like men don't have a lot of
conditional points whereas i think a lot
of women have conditionals so a lot of
women will make their preference as part
of the condition
you know so she might okay a guy has to
be six foot if he's not six foot i'm not
gonna entertain him whereas a guy might
be like okay i'd rather she's four
inches shorter than me but if she's the
same height i can live with that
i think that's do you know what i mean
so i think a lot of them make their
preferences i've never had a guy reject
me
but that's it it's so funny is that um
like you see a lot of men who are like
if you're not xyz like a lot of dating
profiles are like if you're like not xyz
like don't even bother like if you're
learning if you're not we've got
anything we've got to be skinny we've
got but that's that's in our control i
like do not even feel bad bad for women
that get rejected because of their
weight like okay i've been overweight
like i'm like statistically
and it was my own damn fault and you can
lose it
and to be fair like uh
i can say i can say this from like a
thin privileged point of view that i'm
like something privileged you've earned
it one there well i haven't earned it
though i haven't earned it at all you
did from a calorie perspective you ate
less than other people yeah but that's
because of adhd that's like i just don't
eat it
yeah you could call privilege you could
call it eating less
but but then but then it's like there
are some men who love a chunky woman or
someone who are like do you know what it
doesn't matter to me exceptions
exceptions that's the exception is not
the rule yeah exactly and every man
every guy you see that's rich and and
can has has his pick of women yeah yeah
who do they like i'm gonna be real and
most women if you ask them would choose
to be thin like we're gonna be real
about that
um but it still doesn't mean that men
like that's it and you see all these
like male podcasts at the moment who are
like if my wife gets pregnant and
doesn't lose the weight i might be
[ __ ] kidding me that's your wife and
she's going to have your kid i think i i
agree i agree with the men yeah i think
i i agree look at i'm sorry i'm sorry
look at it
i'm sorry i'm not sorry yeah that's very
sorry i i understand i think of a girl
okay if she gains 10 20 pounds but if
you get in like 50 75 pounds after you
get pre or before some girls do it
before
yeah yeah he has a right to leave you
like but then does the woman have the
same rights yes okay good cool cool yes
women women
women leave all the time because of
financial reasons though
finance not fairness
i know but the difference is those are
both of things that you have within your
control does that make sense
i mean
finance is a bit more difficult because
obviously it depends on what job you get
well yeah so arguably if a woman leaves
a man for financial that's probably
harsher than a man leaving her for
weight because it's harder to get good
finances than it is to lose weight
yeah that's uh no i i can't disagree
with that funny my my ex used to ask me
all the time not saying that depends if
she's a mother of my children i think i
would i wouldn't leave because i think
that's because you know it's about the
kids but i think my expert asked me all
the time you know she was a dancer in
you know very good shape she's like oh
if i got like really really like obese
would you still love me i was like i
still love you but we just be friends
if i stayed in the same shape
if i kept the high standards like
because obviously if a girl is attracted
to me not because if part of her
attraction to me is because of my
physical
appearance or prowess or whatever
and then if i lose that i can't then get
pissed off if she loses attraction to me
if that was one of the major key factors
does that make sense or do you think
that's really bad
um
it's yeah it's
situational it's really yeah i
i can't ever argue that's the situation
that's his situation yeah that's your
situation so do you think in that
situation
he's wrong
um i would never like to tell someone
they're wrong i would never like them
but we're asking your opinion so you
know now you if you think it's wrong the
floor is yours go ahead um
well then i think it comes down to
compatibility so if you're a person
that's like well i'm going to really
care about my physique in xyz and
they're like well i'm not then it's like
you're very much not compatible and then
i don't think she's saying she has to
have abs everything oh no yeah
i'm not saying he's just saying don't be
obese yeah but then it's like if you
care
a lot about someone's physicality and
they don't care a lot about their
physical you don't think everyone cares
about physicality a blind person doesn't
a blind person does not why do you look
for the exception to every rule because
you know when you
well you know what i'm talking about in
general no but kindness and obviously
like then there are people who can't
help being paralyzed or like and so
that's like i had a boyfriend who once
was like um
let's be real if i was in a car accident
and you had to care for me the rest of
my life i couldn't sleep with you as
paraplegic i was like yeah of course i'd
stay with you but i know that there's
people who like genuinely would be like
oh i don't know if i could do that i
actually don't know if if you weren't
hot if i had to care for you if i
couldn't sleep with you there are people
who would be like and it doesn't making
them laughter did you know did you know
that women leave men 80 of the time and
if they're college educated it's 90 so
if you get divorced it's 80 of the time
like the woman leaves and one of the
number one predictors of a divorce is
actually if the woman out earns the man
oh i love that i actually love that i
can't lie actually you love that you
don't think that's kind of shitty no i'm
like girl you you go get that you go get
a man like yeah you go get that like
really yeah like why is there like a
lack of empathy for ben is that lack of
empathy but there is because like
they're they're breaking up a family a
lifelong commitment in a home and your
your reaction is you go like go get that
go get the bag sister like i'm so happy
for you when that's actually a really
like that's a sad situation like your
wife is leaving you but then we could
argue that if a mom wanted it enough and
wanted to be enough then we could argue
that but he could be enough but he he
can't because he's she out earned him
like that's that's what i'm saying so in
this case if it was possible for her why
isn't it possible him for him
if she could do it and make that money
why couldn't he i think there are times
where you make less money like yeah my
dad's in the top half a percent of
earners there there were times where he
was barely making any money yeah and my
mom stayed because she's a loyal [ __ ]
and so i'm not going to say you go cis
when you leave a lifelong commitment and
a family you made because you're you out
earned your husband but then it depends
on if your priority is money if your
priority is right so what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that's selfish and
that's wrong and like yeah and you're
saying eugosis and i say i have a lot of
empathy for the men that go through that
yeah and so i just don't understand this
like like why do we immediately take the
woman's side
oh not immediately no and
but right there you did because i gave
you some stats and some numbers and you
like that was and it's okay i think it's
normal actually i think it's like part
of a gynocentric social order yeah
because like we always like our our as a
society we always take the woman's side
like i don't know why that is yeah i
think i think well from my own bias
that's it i would i'm not necessarily i
would actually this is the irony is i
would actually like a partner that out
earns me i would actually like a man i
would like i'm gonna fully be like i
would like a man almost most girls do i
would like a man i would like a man to
out earn me and take care of me however
i love the idea of being financially
independent and being successful and
this is where it's really like uh well
because you know it doesn't work if i
was with a man that was like
i feel bad that you out earned me
i probably wouldn't respect him i can't
really explain why but then i'm also
like i i want to be able to be like i
want i'd like a man that's like i
respect the fact that at some point you
may out earn me and i'll be comfortable
with it but then i'm like
i would like a man to out earn me and
that is yeah yeah but that's that's the
thing like actions have consequences
yeah right and so i think feminism often
tells women we can have everything we
can make a lot of money and have you you
can't like you can't you can make a lot
of money you can have the family and you
can have a husband that out earns you
and actually you know what like my mom
actually did have everything but
everything comes with a cost and people
don't understand what the cost i think
it's the bare minimum like where women
can
there's a bare minimum where you can
actually get everything you want and it
works out but i think but it's the
exception
yeah 100
um just play devil's advocate because
that's my favorite things to do if you
haven't noticed um
so
you just said that you would like a man
who earns more than you and who can take
care of you which
most women
prefer as well
do you not think that's very
anti-feminist of you
no 100 100 and i know that comes from
um
it comes from quote unquote daddy issues
it comes from growing from poverty and
it comes from also being you know i
think it's just natural part of being a
woman
i i can always pick my own experience
yeah yeah so for you do you not think
that desire to have a man who can take
care of you is just part of being a
woman for you
no because i'm not straight
so
yeah do you do
i have a question are you are you bi i'm
pansexual
what is it i don't know what that means
um so pansexual means that you are open
to the possibility of being attracted to
anyone regardless of sex gender you you
did just say you wanted a man though
yeah yeah okay okay if if it was a man
that's it if it was a woman if it was
someone who was transgender it might be
different okay question why because
because i have a couple of friends who
are bi who date men and women and they
apply a different standard for men than
they do for men why is that
um
because if it's about the person it's
not about the gender it's about the
person why would you why do you why do
you apply different standards for a man
and i would argue maybe because i'm a
man but i argue the standards you have
for men are a lot higher than the
standards you would have for a woman why
why do you have why do you apply
different standards depending on the
gender when arguably if you date both
it's actually about the person
um yeah like that's a really good point
i think because arguably it's just
easier to be a man and so therefore
you're like well it's easier
why is it easier to be a man one man i
mean the gender pay gap just says it all
out okay but there's also a gap in like
men commit suicide more yeah men are
dropping out of colleges that's toxic
masculinity that men can't speak about
so then so then why why are we saying
that there's like a patriarchy when men
have at heart too like why are you just
saying you said you you just said women
have it harder than men but if women had
it harder than men like then why are
they i didn't say they had it harder i
just thought it was easy to be a guy
then but okay if it's easier to be a guy
then why do more men commit suicide
because they they feel because of toxic
masculinity which are perpetuated by
both men and women they feel like they
have to be macho and i don't subscribe
to that at all i'm very much like um
well it could be possible that men have
a harder life than women
yeah of course it could be possible of
course it could be okay so that would
like contradict what you said earlier
well this is it it's not black and white
it's not right or wrong yeah gray area
maybe yeah so everything is there's no
like very solid so yeah that's and
even the whole um
rule and exception there's all it's not
one size fits all it's really not where
there is that there are some men who
thrive and succeed because they're a man
because life is easy therefore i'd be
like i would expect you okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you an example my dad's
the half top half a percentage of
earners okay he he's the white man right
that but but here's the thing he worked
80 hours a week my whole life i didn't i
didn't get to see him yeah how how was
that like the patriarchy when my dad put
in 80 hours every week his whole life
from the time i was like a child right
missed a lot a lot of a lot of [ __ ] like
he earned that yeah and i'm never gonna
say that's like no the patriarchy well
the only way but now now he's a white
male ceo yeah right so is is that the
patriarchy or did women not choose to do
that well that's the only way we could
argue is the only definitive answer you
could have is if you had a exact female
replica to be like she likely would not
get where he is that's the only way we
could argue it right so it doesn't take
away from his efforts it doesn't take
away from so then why do we why do we
talk about it at all if you can't if you
have no idea why there's a pay gap
yeah yeah yeah like like it's is it
possible that it's the the industries
that women pick because if you if you
have countries that have more choice so
if you go to like the most egalitarian
countries there's more of a pay gap
rather than less because women choose
jobs with people
and yeah
jobs with objects so like my i'm from a
family of ten
all the boys are engineers none of the
girls are engineers like is it possible
it's a biological difference rather than
a patriarchy yeah no i think i think
well i think the pay gap is more like
within so i don't know if you saw on
international women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being
a financial right
but the pay gap then exists in so a lot
of things where there's a lot of male
actors who will be like i will not uh
sign on to this contract unless i know
my female counterparts are being paid
the same and so i think the pay gap then
comes and well it's also the truth it's
also the trait like disagreeableness so
as women like we're naturally more
agreeable 100 so so we're i'm more i'm
terrible at negotiating i just want to
make everyone happy and i just want to
be like yeah i'll do whatever for
nothing and
um and but that's like men are more
disagreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences no and
gender they are so real so in my studies
um it showed that so
men are more likely to go for so let's
say there's a job and a woman is more
likely to look at a job specification
and go
oh but she's more likely to say no to
herself and she's more likely to go
um
oh i don't know if i'm good enough yeah
whereas a man is more likely to actually
inflate their ability and be like i'm
gonna go for that and it actually
reflects in relationships where a man is
more likely to actually
shoot above and be like yeah i can i can
yes
so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like look i spent a lot of my life being
like i'm a 4 out of 10. i'm
i'm probably about seven but i spent a
lot of my life dating men and people
would be like amy that guy is not in
your league like why do you not and
they're like they're definitely like you
know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
well right right there that's because
men and women men and women value
different things
men value looks more women don't value
looks as much they value things like
social status like a blue check mark
a blue and this is yeah i've dated a guy
with a blue check mark right like we'd
like social status yeah like we'd we'd
be lying if we said we didn't care no no
or or whatever it is like it's it could
be height right it could be like it
could be you know maybe he's not as good
looking facially but he's he makes money
yeah or he makes money yeah right and so
that's why we see there's a gap in that
yeah yeah we don't we don't scream
patriarchy for like men
yeah like but then we don't know that's
it we don't know
is it because of
uh so you've got the biopsychosocial
approach um and that which is what i
tend to um subscribe to because that's
it it's not easy to be like oh it's just
biology or it's just sociology or it's
just your personal my question is like
yeah i just don't even understand like
in this day and age how we are fighting
the patriarchy like what more can they
do i can do any job i want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like i don't even
know like i don't even know what i need
feminism for now like i can't think of
one thing um i have a
question going back to what you said and
i think it's bad but i want to
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men
is because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy
you should expect more from them
or they have advantages
right more so than women right
so
my question then
is
would you
apply a higher standard to a white woman
over for example a black male
yeah you would i would really
so you would expect the white woman to
earn a certain amount
to be taller than you
to make you feel protected and to be
able to provide for you more so than if
you were getting to know a black male
all right well
then it's the intersection between race
and gender but that's it as a
westernized white woman i'm well aware
of my privilege
um and it's like i know that
like ah it depends on well that's it it
depends on
oh it's tough it's because i'll be i'll
be honest like i think women just always
apply a higher standard to men than
women because it meant regardless of
what race they are so say like we go for
a job interview oh wait wait you're
non-binary me and him
yeah who are you dating
[Applause]
like who you
who are you picking yeah he probably
makes more money than me yeah but then
but then but then being a female i'd
probably be like is money my most
important or is it emotional connection
and how funny you are like it would
depend on what as a woman i think i
would oh i don't know
that's it would would i well as a woman
that doesn't necessarily want kids any
time soon and he's quite financially
independent i probably wouldn't be like
money probably wouldn't be my priority
so then i'd be like what physical
attractive would come into it but then
funny so something okay so it's really
oh no but it's really no but it's really
[Applause]
is it just money is it protection
because i'm also quite scrappy so i can
hold my own as well i don't want a man
to protect me because i'll fight do you
think you could fight me
yeah
do you think you could beat me in a
fight yeah because i'll just go straight
for the eyes straight with the eyes and
you are disabled
i will i will let you believe that
that's it that's if you're trying to
fight me and i blind you in one eye
you're not gonna
you're not gonna i'm like not even okay
you can blind him in one eye and he'll
knock you out
i don't think if someone's blinding you
in an audience
i think that's a very nice i'm not
allowed to hit women so yeah okay this
is a very nice that's a double standard
hit a woman i'm i'ma hit me thank you i
think if a girl hits a man he can knock
her out he can knock her out yeah yeah
you can yeah i would only
fellas don't do it it's not worth it you
know you're gonna get double the jail
time it's not worth it but then again
that's a double standard because then
other men will start to hit you and be
like you hit a woman no no if she
started on you you've got every right
every right i would say if my life is
threatened then fine but if if my life
isn't threatened i'll grapple her but i
won't i won't punch her in the throat i
think the majority of girls will hit a
guy if push comes to shelf because they
believe that one they're protected and
two they're not gonna oh did you did you
know statistically in terms of the the
line of crossing over to physical abuse
women crossed that line more
statistically speaking i would believe
that but it's actually but all it is is
that when men cross the line
men are when naturally more aggressive
and violent so when men cross the line
there are there are harsher consequences
right for the woman physically but like
and i mean like i mean just like a woman
if she gets annoyed she goes oh for
[ __ ] sake like yeah do you know what i
mean like women actually cross that line
more than men do
yeah i can get like i like to punch
people in the arm i like to just be like
i don't know why but i'll just but
that's technically abuse that's
definitely i've technically just abused
you if a man punched me and especially
we were in public people were like what
the [ __ ] you just punched it and i'll be
like
but no i'm a
i think
again it's responsibility that if i hit
someone man woman young old black white
i'm like i'm fully ready for you to hit
me back at least the equality i respect
it i'm fully ready for you
i will not hit someone if i'm not
prepared for them to hit me back okay i
will not yeah okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
read some super chat so
4.99 for mr ryder okay equality and
female liberation because
is because white men allowed it
do you include that in um
you know in
non-white countries that's my question
is feminism rampant in non-white
countries i don't know how i like
feminism
in nigeria i couldn't tell you is it i
don't know okay i was like i think you
said i know oh i don't i don't know oh
yeah because i can't think of a white
country or a black like a country that's
not maybe japan i could see japan maybe
but then but then you also would argue
as a black male
like are you for feminism or supportive
or like open to like yeah if you ask my
opinion i i honestly believe that
current day feminism
i'm not for it mainly because i believe
it destroys the black community
personally
okay fair enough yeah i think it i think
it massively has destroyed the black
nuclear family in the western world
which is why
it's interesting because black
immigrants do significantly better than
the black locals in any western country
and a big part of that is because they
have a nuclear family when they come
over i
yeah i i can't really comment i don't
know enough about it so comment on it
yeah
um okay the next one zantiance i don't
know anything about that so i was like
um i love this person not caring about
the consequence regardless of whom they
hurt especially if it hurts your family
prider
or
they the close to you you are a
narcissist trending line of sociopathy a
hundred percent alone
sorry
i have diagnosed so um i have diagnosed
bpd and it's proven that you can't have
both bpt and mpd yeah so take that
oh so i tried to kill myself because i
hated myself for three years so
definitely not a narcissist baby okay
guys who don't care guys who don't care
don't have options guys with options are
as discerning as their options
um
let's see i'm going down going down see
if there's any more
oh i think that's it okay oh wait
another i thought i saw one more
everyone writes themselves a seven kevin
samuels is right i that's what i say
that too oh i don't know this is like
wrong oh yeah so okay if you had to pick
six or eight what would you pick for
yourself you can't you can't pick up i'd
go like go low i guess it's like a six
but i think men would go eight i really
think of men men would go eight
for themselves yeah
it depends on humble
yeah what do you rate yourself one to
ten
i can't use seven
i think i'll choose a six because who i
would rate a ten
i'd rate mark will be jordan at ten
michael b jordan yeah okay like like a
guy who's a 10 is a guy who has the
status has the success has done he
hasn't he has the looks no i'm just
talking about lex just purely unless
that purely looks
if ah i don't know i'll i'll let others
be the judge i'll let others be that's
fine just figure it out i don't know one
to ten i feel like i feel like you have
to i feel like you have to let your
results
your results show where you land your
results show yeah
does that make sense yeah so it's all
good someone's saying like oh i'm really
good at trading right but if you haven't
made any money from trading how good are
you okay so based on your results one to
ten what would you rank yourself seven
seven guys i'm not going any lower
this is so funny because um
like
girl oh actually i currently talk about
girls or guys but like you know a lot of
girls will kind of be like oh so if
their ex gets a new girl girls will tend
to be like they're a downgrade to feel
better to yourself fit about themselves
but there was i saw a tic toc and it was
like you don't want your x-man to
downgrade you want if anything
you want him to be like with a hot
person because then you're like this is
his caliber this is his category this is
his like league i would rather be the
ugliest girl a man has dated than be the
best looking girl a man has dated that's
my personal opinion
i've had a few girls come back just as
my career
no no but like no i would i i'm petty in
the i'd rather you quote unquote
downgraded but imagine then being in
that pool and being like oh
you think that i am so
it's horrible to reduce people's numbers
but let's say let's say that we're we're
all sevens and our x's then go on to
date fours you're like you think i'm the
same as a four
oh
you think i would have four i would say
i would say your life got worse after me
baby yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm teddy yeah
yeah i'm playing
adds to your attractiveness
i think heart's looking different i
would say like one to ten i would say
five maybe six because i think that if
you're an eight to ten you can model i
don't think i could model and my results
have shown that i cannot model so
so i would say five maybe six on a good
day that's what i would give myself okay
but i also think that like like for a
girl this is how i divide it it's like
your body your face is like the starting
point like so for guys this is how i do
it yeah so let's say if a guy was a five
but he was like in the top like 20 of
height eight in height right divided by
two you're six point five
or is that a seven i don't know
i don't know what that is for women
for a woman it's like your body
basically it's the same thing it's like
your face plus your body and like i
think men are a lot
like
guys
guys don't forget a lot for an ass let
me tell you oh they're frozen 100
percent
everything that's like
i got a lot more attention when my bum
got big and i was like interesting
because i shaved my head clean bald and
i shaved my head clean bored to be
conventionally unattractive and so i was
like i want to be ugly right
um so i wanted to focus on myself and
not date men i was like so if men think
i'm ugly they're not gonna come towards
me they're not gonna i'm gonna wonder
like why like you seem to just have like
a slight disdain for men when we talk
no like i just wanted to be ugly because
i was like i need to spend time with
myself because i was very co-dependent
on their like appreciation i was very
co-dependent upon them
i think it's okay like to let them gas
you up a little bit yeah like i don't
why is that bad it was all my
self-control that i was like if i if
you're not gonna get it forever when
you're 50. it's not going to be there
i'll take it now
i feel it was more of an insecurity
selfish i was like if i feel ugly i'm
obviously not going to try and
communicate with men if i feel ugly and
i feel insecure but unfortunately i felt
amazing when i shaved my head but then
my body got a lot better and so and i
get men all the time so i i did a poem i
was like right should i grow my hair
should i keep it short and majority of
men were like you look better with long
hair yeah
then the men that i know are like you
look really hot and i'm like i don't
know because they're crying
but it's because it's not because of my
hair on my face it's because of my ass
but my ass got so much better and they
were like that is what we're going to
take up i have another question for this
is male rating things he went face in
height right yeah what about his body
um because i play less of a pop
actually i asked a girl this the other
day but she was 6'3 so keep that in mind
my friends are all tall because like i
play volleyball
so my short friends are five five
um let's see i asked her i
for me but also i think tall girls like
value height like we'd rather have like
i could not do someone like a lot
shorter than me like that would not work
um i think like muscles is like a bonus
like i think it probably adds a point
but i think like if you're overweight
like that subtracts like three
yeah
yeah yeah
so would you take how how tall are you
how tall are you in heels i don't know
like six three
i think the shortest you sure you were
in heels no i don't think two maybe six
i don't know i'm five eleven and a half
i don't know if i feel like you're the
same height i mean in the hills
i don't know i feel like i'm 60. would
you i feel like we should yeah who would
you um would you rather would you rather
a guy who is 6'2 by average body or
would you rather a guy who is 510 but
really good
over the 510 really good body yeah wow
height is i knew height was a thing but
then shorter than me if you said six
foot i might have switched it uh but i
just can't six boy you want like six in
there yeah
six foot yeah like if you said like six
two versus six four i might have picked
body but like like for girls it's like
we don't i don't care like it's just
like my height ish or taller
like once you start getting like
noticeably shorter than me i'm like
doesn't matter how how big that junk is
how many how much of an eight-pack you
got
don't matter
what's that
yeah go ahead go ahead okay um well i
should go um why don't you ask why don't
you ask me a question ask you a question
is that something we could disagree on
is there anything that we disagree on i
feel like there must be something is
there something we just have the same
sadistic sense of humor
messaging earlier today um what do we
disagree on um
i don't know you've probably watched
more of my content ouch ouch
you found me first right
you messaged me first
did i you didn't know but that was
because of ali it was it was okay
uh have you seen anything you disagree
with me on
do you think men have the right to cheat
i think they have the right to cheat you
have to
do you have to define what cheating is
to you
is cheating lying or is cheating
exercising options without lying i think
well it would be
do you think that's good for a nuclear
family to have a dad
it's like the man in him is like ah
maybe the matter is like you're just
like family he's like you know i can't
be he she'll be fine i mean you know
it's a stress reliever
um nuclear family it's not good for the
nuclear family it's not oh long term
it's not because if you
if you get someone else pregnant and you
have to provide that's taken away from
the families yeah it's only good for the
nuclear family if
you don't get caught
so do you think do you think cheating is
okay if you don't get caught no
i don't think lying is okay full stop
okay so cheating is lying yeah really
yeah but if you say listen if you're
with me this is how it is
do your thing yeah no i agree with
because i've done that really yeah were
you like she was your girlfriend or was
just no like someone i started dating
i'm just like just so you know
like you whether you're excused to me
i'm fine but i'm going to be dating
other people doing other things and if
that's not for you then maybe we should
just stay friends and then at first she
was like okay what's up that's a power
move
that's a power i just rather be honest
man like i don't i don't know i'm not
desperate
i get it i get it um that's what i would
say i don't think it's okay to cheat
it's not okay to lie but also like women
cheat as well oh yeah no they both do i
think women might cheat more than mine i
think i think now men do cheat a bit
more but i think i think men it's like
one in three i think women it's one in
four i think this is kevin samuel stat i
think it's 28 men 24 women cheat
so women cheat almost as much as men do
yeah
well that's self-reported i think women
will lie i i think they've been so much
better at lying
and i think women don't count things
like you know
like i i've i've seen certain things
where i'm like
your boyfriend know about that like and
i that's not like going home with a guy
but i've seen girls like twerking on
another guy at a bar where i'm like um
just makes me like well i i've got a
question for you
what
what
kind of guy would you not entertain
seriously
and not energy
outside of being a criminal
do you mean like like
i would
i wouldn't give him the time of day you
wouldn't like you would be like this
isn't non-negotiable
five-five
outside of height and criminal
outside of her
liberal
it's like the first thing i'm like so
what do you think
okay
yeah super laughs so it goes so goes
criminal height and then political
party yeah what do you
do you think that do you think that's a
bit um
not harsh do you think that's a bit
ex
extreme
excessive excessive yeah not extreme do
you not think that's a bit excessive do
you think do you really think that is
completely completely impossible for you
to
build a life with someone who's on the
other side of the spectrum i think if he
was indifferent
i could if he just doesn't care about
politics
i've dated guys that like just don't
they're like i don't watch i don't care
yeah but i think that it's more of like
a mindset thing yeah and like i just
don't like the like no offense like the
victim mentality like the
like femi i really hate feminism i like
feel this strongly in my soul
no fans
if i'm not a victim that's i'm not a
victim i'm like no you're you're you're
the exception
i think in relation to politics as well
it's like religion is a very similar one
as well that it's a lot easier to be
with someone who's like i don't i don't
really have an opinion on religion i
would never say there is no god but i'm
also not someone who's like there is no
god i think i can get over religion
[Music]
um but then like
even like people who like a lot of
people i know who are vegan and
vegetarian like literally couldn't date
a meat eater yeah and then there's a lot
of and then there's a lot of meat eaters
who are like i couldn't date a vegan or
a vegetarian and i'm just there like oh
no they're really mellows i'm like it
doesn't really matter i'm very
indifferent to a lot of things i'm very
on the fence or in the middle of yeah
uh it happens a lot
where people when they're younger
they're very
left-wing and then as they get older
they tend to become more conservative
why do you think that is
because
um i think it's because you start to see
the consequences of like life so for
example like free [ __ ]
and when it starts coming out like a
more and more your paycheck like you
know what's funny they as you survey
people do you care about the environment
people say yes yeah you survey them
would you be cool with taking 20 out of
every paycheck for the environment they
say no
and i think that's over time
life show that's what i would guess yeah
yeah
yeah
i think i think a big part of it is that
i think society has continuously moved
in a
liberal direction
and i think what happens is that the
goal post for what is seen as
conservative and seen as liberal i think
move
so like for example someone who was
liberal 20 years ago would be seen as
conservative today
oh i actually i agree with that too
i agree with that because it's weird
because i i i think i said this before
but i find myself
my views haven't changed
but i would say i'm more left-leaning
than left-wing now because i feel like
what's it considered left-wing i just
don't agree with
but i would still say i'm left-leaning
i don't know but both my parents are
conservative
yeah but honestly if you're an actor
what are you guys
like but i think this is why a lot of
people who like choose actively choose
not to vote as well and you get
demonized if you choose not to vote but
i'm like
i can literally look at every party's
policies when it comes to voting i'm
like there's gonna be something i agree
with with everyone there's gonna be
something that i'm like yeah do you know
what i can i'm like then you kind of
have to uh it gets to uh did you know
it's so fun you know what determines
your political leanings i researched
this a while ago because i could not
figure out off the top of my head i'd
say like parents okay like what is it i
i could not i could not figure out
because i am a big ball of fun okay and
i i'm i'm a fun gal and like
and like and like i was like why am i
like like all my friends are liberal
like i'm like conservatives are so
boring
and it's because if i take a personality
test it says i'm super loft like i'm
very i'm very i can see that yeah yeah
i'm very creative i'm very open to new
experience i'm like like it's like if
you meet someone that lives in a van you
assume they're liberal because they're
open to new experience like if a
conservative buys a dog they want a dog
that's going to protect them if a
liberal buys a dog they want a dog
that's like funny and goofy you guys met
my dog which one is she
yeah and so um but then so that's like
one part of it that's like half of it
right the other so then it determines
three factors okay yeah so and it
changes based on your age so if you're
under the age of like i don't know
25-ish ballpark
the number one factor that determines
your political leanings is your parents
okay yeah the number two is your
environment number three is like who
you're dating whatever
but then you're the person you marry is
the number one influence on your
political leanings and i think we've all
seen someone date someone on the other
end of the spectrum and kind of move a
little that way very true yeah yeah
number two then becomes your environment
your parents becomes last over time
yeah and like so the second so it makes
sense that you're more left-leaning
because you're 27 yeah and your
environment is you're i can imagine
being an actor you're among like yeah
i've
or have you always been like this
been like what like like more left
leaning i mean i know you said like
you're left but you're not left but
yeah i i've always been definitely like
you said like i've got a lot of you know
i'm very open and very creative so
naturally those things are quite yeah
yeah liberal
um but i've clashed a lot with people in
my industry over certain things
yeah um
of hamilton and i think i don't know
it's
you know the cliche thing is you know my
parents they're from nigeria they came
here with 200 pounds of suitcase and
they're both like
have had amazing success for themselves
like my dad owns several properties
around london my mom just wrote a
million dollar book whatever
so i'm kind of like
like the whole benefits thing and this
is
[Music]
it's weird because
i have this whole when you when you like
my when my dad had me right he was
he was in uni studying
accountancy he had a he worked a job as
a night security card and he was a taxi
driver so he had two jobs and studying
and a newborn baby and then there's some
people out here they just don't want to
work
and the government's like here's free
money and i'm like how does that i don't
understand that that doesn't make sense
to me because of how i've grown up have
you seen the video of that guy that said
he moved to california so he could be
homeless
because they were paying so much to be
homeless there
and he's like yeah like no it's great
like i just get to be homeless here i
moved from texas to california to be
homeless i just don't get it that is the
definition of work smarter not harder
because you're literally not doing any
hard work but you're like reaping the
benefits that's that's why that is
that is why and then i get it because
thing is like the more you earn the more
you pay in tax and like i remember what
i'm not gonna say but like just before
the pandemic hit i was in a western show
i was doing a good part and i was owning
really good money and then that tax hit
me hard and then covered it and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah i was
like why do i have to pay someone i was
like for what and then it was like
yeah i don't know
yeah i don't know i didn't i i think as
i've gotten older
and
you know it's weird because i was like
oh is it kind of accumulatively as you
do better your views change because
you're like you want to hold on to
what's yours
um but yeah i don't know i don't know
well and i think you also start to see
like
i don't know over time i see the reality
of like hard work like more you like you
see like a lot of people
i don't want to say all because there's
exceptions to every rule but i see a lot
of people that are unsuccessful just
because they're lazy and they don't work
hard and like a lot of people that like
really have the talent and could be but
they just like don't do anything
and it's it kind of makes you feel some
type of way when they're getting like
free [ __ ] when you're like like for you
don't do [ __ ] you know you ever see i
don't know i've met people like that
yeah
no i feel it um i'm gonna read some
super chats so
twenty dollars from
zentians you are my guy no you he's your
daddy right now
daddy right now what do you want me to
call you
they have a disdain to me i'm really
appreciative of you supporting the
stream sir
i warned her before about the comments
um okay current day feminism third wave
and onward is 100 trash due to toxic
femininity but i want to thank feminism
for the ability to sleep with women
without commitment cheers
big facts
big facts
i mean
each to their own like oh my gosh i
think about that a lot i'm like before
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you this
that's
area code method face body personality
is how would you say that's how guys
rank girls face body than personality
yes yeah or so for some guys it's body
face and personality
i've heard mixed things i've heard that
and then sometimes
i've heard like guys will look at your
body glance at your face and go back
i agree i think you know what since this
whole because everyone's so like on
fitness yeah in our generation i i would
say it goes body face
yeah i think it's because there's a lot
less in shape
but i also it
like 20 of girls by just being in like
the right body fat percentage
i think they're a big part as well as
like obviously like if you uh it depends
on like if you're in a bar people are
obviously gonna first look at like like
i wore i wear tight dresses for a reason
because i know that men are gonna be
like she's got a good bump then i'll
look at my face and then they'll try and
talk did you look at her ass when she
when she got here
no i didn't okay
are you offended no i get offended
keep my eyes above waste at all times
i work hard and i make it work for me
okay but literally if so if it was like
a guy that like let's say um i was
working with them or on a project or
like blah blah i'd like them first to be
like i'd like them to be like oh
personality first claim work with you i
know you and then be like no no but if
i'm walking into a bar i fully know that
they're either gonna look at my body
first or my face first like 100
i'm i'mma just say right now it doesn't
matter how good your personality is if
he doesn't find you attractive ain't
nothing happening
but they might find you attractive after
so i've had a lot of guys be like
initially oh that well there's a lot of
i've had a lot of guy friends try to
transition from friends to like lovers
like i said and i'm like i i'm not i'm
not really i'm not really hot but i'm
not you're you're a woman but do not do
not think that from when they first met
you they would have slept with you if
you put on a plate for them
some of them know because some of them i
got rejected by and then they suddenly
were like oh you're actually really nice
you're actually funny and i was like but
also actually that does go in line with
the fact that i have gotten hotter i
have gone hot in the past couple of
years yeah have you lost weight or
something
no
you're just not bald now uh
no it's the ass it's the ass i'm not
joking
what was your point what are you gonna
say oh okay i wanna i wanna run
something by you i'm gonna oh my god oh
you would vote for me okay i wanna get
grilled okay okay okay no no this is for
the this is for the feminists so
so i i have a um
i have i wanna run for an office okay
and this is this is what i would
advocate for
i'm so scared
let's return our rights
hear me out okay oh yeah yeah i don't
like to drive
i'm not even a good driver
[Music]
in saudi arabia these girls they're like
oh they can't drive i'm like we didn't
have to
then on top of that voting right
right voting okay why pay attention to
politics and we could just let the men
do it for us okay
then i don't have to do that okay hear
me out everyone wanted to work who who
are these women that wanted to work i
could be chilling at home on youtube
please get married at 18. sugar daddy
afraid of marriage
return it return it i am ready to be a
housewife i i'm not against i'm not
against that okay so
so this is what and like nowadays this
is where we fumbled the bag in the back
in the old days they would have to like
do the laundry manually all this stuff
right
nowadays it's automated if we just
waited
like another couple decades
it would be an easy housewife role
roomba
automated laundry you don't have to hang
it outside like i would be like
and we gotta cook when there's there's
ubereats now and you there's like all
these cooking services like i think i
would i would be lying if i like i know
there are some women who maybe feel like
they've got a lot to prove if you told
me i could live life on easy mode i'd
live life on easy mode i think women
live life on easy right i would live
life we do we do live life on easy mode
i think you know how many advantages you
get just from being a young attractive
girl that men don't get i think that a
lot i'm gonna be and this is this is
very anti-feminist to me but i think a
lot of women
don't live life on easy mode because
they feel like they have something to
prove and i'm like i'm not gonna lie i'm
100 if in if a rich old man that i found
physically attractive and therefore
would happily have sex with if they were
like amy i'm gonna financially take care
of you you can not work you can do her
dms are open
100 please 100
if if a rich you don't need to be rich
you need to just be if a man and this is
anti-feminist but if a man said to me
amy i will take care of you you don't
have to work you just have to and
genuinely yeah if a man wins what do you
get what do you get what do you get
sexual favors on command
not on command what do you mean he's
taking care of all your bills yeah but
sometimes the coochie is tight sometimes
it's upside down i'm tired like
everybody's taking care 100 of the bills
i'll make it work
come on
but then that makes it working a lot
would you let him sleep with other women
um
that would depend on if i was like
emotionally attached to him if like oh
that would like
he's only going to take care of you
and fund your entire lifestyle that you
want
if you accept him he's going to sleep
with other women yeah but then i'd sleep
with other men no no no no you can't see
what i mean because you're not paying
for his life
but to be fair i have a vibrator so i'd
be like you know what if i've got a
comfortable life and it's just sex like
if i really cared about him then that's
like different but if i was only with
him for the money and the comfort no you
care you can't you care about him you
care about him you like who he is he
says i'm gonna take care of you you live
the lifestyle you want but you have to
accept that he's gonna sleep with other
people
i wouldn't like it but knowing me i've
stayed with cheetahs i've stayed with
cheetahs so i'd just be like not
cheating because he's not lying
do you know what i think that would be
more on me that would be more on me if
he cheated and my self-esteem or my
worth or xyz if i went amy do you want
commitment stability uh exclusivity or
do you want discomfort in this lifestyle
and if i went
i prioritize this comfort in this
lifestyle then i would have to be like
i'm asking you right now would you
prioritize that or would you prioritize
exclusivity
i don't know i don't i don't know i
didn't
what did you choose
i already know what your issues
you're taking that lifestyle baby oh no
i'm kidding i wouldn't do cheating
actually you wouldn't you if you could
if you could give you the lifestyle that
you wanted you wouldn't take it i'll go
to my dad what do i need him for her
no no i mean i can't but like like they
always say like women's have mating
strategies yeah and there's five mating
strategies have i talked to you about
these no for women
yeah and i always forget the fifth so if
anyone in the chat knows the fifth i
forget these but it's like so when we
see a guy there's like five guys
basically that represent so one is the
guy at the foam cannon party well i
don't know what that is what's just they
call they call a guy that's a man of
spirit term the guys they got the chat
gets it
that's that's the guy that's like really
hot like really just like physically
attractive like he has the jeans we want
right so that's like the girls that have
like a one-night stand with the guy
that's that's why they call him they met
him at the foam cannon
i don't know i don't know what came over
yeah that's that's guy number one okay
strategy jeans right yeah next mating
strategy parental investment yeah so we
want to know this is a guy we meet and
we think he would stick around if i we
got if i got pregnant like i think he
would like provide time yeah second
thing is money so i think he could be he
has the resources kind of like the alpha
beta thing yeah but like he has the
resources to like take care of the guy
fourth is legacy now legacy is like not
embarrassing the family and like having
like character be like work ethic like
that sort of thing
yeah and that's like when i was talking
to my friend torsha who taught me this
the other day um would you go subscribe
to her channel um
she she said that's what when i talk
about like what i look for like that's
what i look for is legacy yeah because
like the the
money isn't as big like i'd rather have
legacy yeah yeah so like i don't want a
guy that's like embarrassing because
even if like you don't get caught
you know what's even worse i think
they're getting worse than getting
cheated on is like everybody knew you
got cheated on yeah i'm telling you yeah
that is the worst that is the worst
feeling
embarrassing so and i don't know what
the fifth one was if anyone knows in the
chat because i forget well do you know
the
different mating strategies for men
um i would guess so so low body count
because they want to make sure the kid
is theirs
yep so and then i would guess
um
like like someone that would be a good
mother of the kid so like femininity
maybe like being like kind that sort of
thing um
in shape because like the the hips right
they like wide hips that's what i got
you guys like ass because it's like the
birthing hips or something there's like
men when i say men in the west men
haven't always liked but in the black
culture always has been but i think the
only reason that arse is a thing now is
because hip-hop is mainstream well i
think it's like like i don't even think
it's ass in itself but like like the
hits the hits child-bearing hits
yeah yeah and then like the boobs is
like i don't know the kids suck i don't
know
there's something with that too
um
yeah i think that's all the ones i could
think of off the top of my head
i would agree i would agree
i think um
i think the promiscuous is
honestly how quickly she sleeps with him
promiscuous i think like if she sleeps
in quickly he's gonna see her as more
promiscuous than if she doesn't do you
do you think that
if she has a kid that changes
whether he sees it 100 yeah because you
can't you can't yeah i'll be honest
would you would you tell your female
clients if they have a kid to like kind
of throw that strategy out the door like
he he ain't going to see you as pro like
that i would i would say that having a
child to a man is compromising
for him yeah and i would explain that it
is natural in male because as the male
it is we are expected to sacrifice for
the woman and for the child
and there is nothing biologically and
naturally worse than a man sacrificing
himself for offspring that isn't his
that's why in the lion kingdom the first
thing that male does is he kills the
cubs boy if a new male takes over the
pride he kills those cubs because he's
like if i'm putting my life on the line
for this pride best believe i'm doing it
for my genes not anyone else's
so
um
i'll be honest i know a few of my
friends would be like honestly they'd
have sex with someone who had a kid but
they they probably wouldn't marry them
if they have other options they probably
wouldn't
but do you think like girls should still
hold out if they have a kid hold out
like on sex
because how is he gonna view you as not
promiscuous if you have a child i would
say
i would say yes because
here's the thing when a woman
when i say hold out not like hold out
for three months when a woman doesn't
engage in sex with a guy quickly that's
part of the vetting process for saying
which is he the kind of guy who's going
to stick around for you
is he the kind of guy and if he's not
that kind of guy
then he's not going to
he's not going to stick around if you
don't
do what i mean but if he is the kind of
guy who could stick around then it's in
your interest to not be sexually quick
with him because
that's the best way as opposed to being
sexually quickly because then he'd be
like okay well probably not do you know
what i mean do you so it's interesting
cause i always hear from like in the red
pill they tell guys if she doesn't sleep
with you within three dates to like move
on because she's not genuinely attracted
to you
i don't i don't i don't i don't agree
with that i think it's i have a rule i
tell guys who are coach if she doesn't
kiss you within the first three dates
for sure move on
but i would say the biggest thing is
having sexual progression
so if let's say she doesn't kiss you on
the first date but then actually kisses
you in the second date but let's say
it's not a full-out kiss it's like a
peck on her lips or whatever fine let's
say the third day she kisses you with
some tongues there's a better hands
going somewhere there's sexual
progression that's good
and in fact if i was being honest if i
was dating a girl i'm gonna take that
girl more seriously than the girl who
has sex with me on the first date
whereas if it's a girl if you don't get
anything for the three dates facts move
on she's not into you she doesn't have
general desire if she doesn't sleep with
you no maybe she's just a woman who's
worthy of being a wife when do you okay
when would you tell a guy
to like like to move on if she
like how long would you say look at she
hasn't slept with you within that long
you gotta go boy
i had this situation recently um
if she hasn't slept yeah yeah
have they done anything or no
have they done have they done nothing
nothing past making out
nothing past making out yeah
they say okay let's say you're going on
an average one day a week
right after five weeks you haven't you
haven't gone past kissing after five
weeks nah bounce bro
go i'm out cause it's interesting
because i'll hear men like i kind of
understand both sides a little bit yeah
what would you say
would you tell men
like men
gosh it's hard because
god it depends on the girl you're like
if it was me i didn't kiss it till the
sixth month
oh god six no i would tell them to move
on six months
no it's just more like like okay i know
girls that'll make guys hold out because
they don't view them in that way
i think guys don't view them or she
doesn't view like like she'll sleep with
one guy right away but she'll make
another guy wait because she doesn't
view the one guy in that way
like she's more in that way she's more
attracted to the guy that she slept with
straight away yeah
i think she's more physically attracted
yeah but i don't think that's the one
who she values more
because women who i think women who
you tell me what you think i think women
if they're
if a guy
doesn't have a lot of
qualities that's good for long term so
let's say
stable whatever but he's
really attractive she'll sleep with him
because she's like oh well whatever
but if he does have a lot of great
qualities long term and she's attracted
to him
if she's clever she won't sleep with him
straight away
because she knows that probably is going
to eliminate her as long term in his
eyes
i would say sometimes sometimes but it
kind of it kind of goes bad i hate these
terms i hate doing it
but i think a lot of times the girls
like views the one guy is more beta
i think i think i think there's like
there's like
a level of attraction where a girl will
have and i just think like
i don't that's the problem is it's
really hard to distinguish and it really
depends on the girl
yeah you don't do you know what i'm
saying yeah because i think i've had it
like i i've had it where
sounds so bad i know i'll just be honest
i've had it where like really attractive
girls
have been like
some have like just slept with these
straight away
and then they've been girls who
arguably a lot of guys she's attractive
not as attractive but because she really
didn't want to [ __ ] her up she
she didn't sleep with me straight away
because she was like i don't want to
lose the chance of having this guy
as a serious term i don't know that
might be what she told you maybe well i
mean
i'll be honest man it happens
well she definitely asked me to be uh
her boyfriend or whatever yeah oh my god
how'd that go for her
uh one of two of them i said no one of
them
we were together for two oh yeah yeah
okay
in relation to like the whole like alpha
beta thing it's so funny because
i'm like oh would i rather
sleep with like an alpha on the first
date because i'm like oh i'm really
attracted to you and like you make me
feel a certain way
or
would i rather sleep with a beta because
i'm like well i don't see any longevity
or any like worth or value in you so i
actually really can't decide in
i think you do see value in the beta
just not the same as the alpha oh yeah
yeah yeah so no because you know the
alpha's not going to stick around but
the beta probably would yeah so that's
that was like yeah to say no was like
the wrong kind of term but it's like
actually like
yeah and my dating life is very that's
i'm very much like [ __ ] there really is
no one-size-fits-all because
i've been giving my time and attention
to men that maybe don't really respect
me and then i went on a date with a man
that really did respect me and i was
like right
i do recognize that i really want to
sleep with you more than anyone else but
i don't want to sleep with you but then
all my past relationships
i
slept with them on the first day and
they still like yeah i'm gonna like
commit to you and so it's like oh it's
yeah can i be honest what i think that
might have been and that's no disrespect
to them i don't know
um and i'm only saying this because
you said that in your previous
relationships that your friends were
like they're they were punching like you
out there league
there are a lot of guys who are in
relationships
because that is their only access to
regular sexual
intimacy
um
and they'll commit to the first girl
that comes along not saying that's not
not saying that was the case or rather
not that they'll commit to the first
goal that comes along but they are more
like they have more of an incentive to
commit to a girl who gives them that
access if that is something that they
don't get on a regular basis does that
make sense yeah no
i'll actually agree with that because i
had one boyfriend that's the one who was
very he was very
he'd slept with a lot of women he was
very in demand but then he actually was
a very toxic awful human being and
treating me really badly so i'm like in
my mind when you were talking i was like
oh he's the exception because he got a
lot of attention
but then i'm like oh but then it's kind
of like it it almost enabled him to
treat me really badly and so this is i'm
a very big
point in my life where i've i've got a
self-imposed deadline of april where i'm
going to stop dating i'm going to stop
if anything
i don't feel like i'm disrespecting
myself by being casual but i'm now like
i've done that i've had fun i'm not
really benefiting and i don't feel like
men are taking me seriously because i'm
casual and not that i want them to you
know everyone who's like oh you're not
my girlfriend i'm like that's cool i
don't want to be your girlfriend but now
i'm like oh actually
i think if anything oh this sounds awful
because i hate to
be like low caliber but i'm like oh no
like i know what i bring to the table
and i actually know that that's it
casual aside body count aside i know
that i'm actually quite a high caliber
and i bring a lot to the table but i do
have to be real and be like maybe my
behavior doesn't show men that and i'm
like you know what come april i'm
entering my hot villain era i'm gonna
make all of the men who did me and that
because that's what happens is men that
cheated on me or did me wrong or didn't
want to commit to me
they all come back around at some point
and they all drop in my dms and i'm like
this is like really interesting
something
probably but i don't sleep with them but
they they still go so my really really
toxic ex we broke up three years ago
he's the one that told me that he had
cancer i dropped my job my home my
friends i i literally gave up i got
really unwell because he was
awfully cheap on me the whole time i
really allowed him to treat me really
badly and i'm like you cheated on me you
didn't respect me you ended things with
me
why are you still messaging me three
years later
when i know you've got a yell but he
knows as well that i'm sex yeah sex and
i'm like wow i think i think from the
relationship that it sounds like you've
had he
believes that he can still
control you
he does that so you you answer though
don't you
oh you don't no so well
so i posted a picture on my instagram of
me in like some lingerie it looked good
i was thirst trapping i was seeking
attention no shame in this game and he
went
oh that's my saturday sorted as in i'm
gonna masturbate over you and i was like
you you've got a girl this is not
appropriate and then he went i'd love to
see more pictures and i went yeah there
are more but they're not for you and he
was like oh okay and i was like to be
fair yeah i should just ignore it i
should just and so every time i reply i
am giving him a bit of power and i am
yeah do you think that women have an
expiration date on dating
like do you think there's any urgency to
like find a husband sooner rather than
later
um i
yeah i i think like i wouldn't like to
say yes but i think so i think yeah even
you've got like the whole you're
now then well they say that men get
better with age and women
at some point too but yeah they say that
that's it you know men are allowed to be
a silver fox whereas women have to get
botox and dye their hair and again
you've got like the whole biological
like well it's just like we get we get
that attention immediately so like i
remember being like 15 16 and i was like
why is everyone paying attention to me
now you know braces came off and [ __ ]
like
and but like men don't have that like
they're they're like invisible to the
world so it's like a trade-off yeah so
so right now you there's there are
things you've admitted on this show that
you you get special favors and stuff
because you're a young 100 percent
audience yeah right but men don't get
that for the first half of their lives
so like
people will cry and say it's like not
fair but it's like the most fair thing
ever and it's a very small percentage of
men that actually become silver fox it's
not the majority most men don't even get
half that level of advantage that most
young attractive women have and i think
well then as a man gets older it then
comes to um
what you can provide and an older man
you're gonna maybe assume you've got
more finances you've got more xyz i
don't know
i think men i actually don't know i find
women a lot more attractive than men
like categorically women are a lot more
interesting than me today over here oh
yes yeah even though men are a lot more
attractive than men
but it's as a man gets older you do just
assume like you're probably going to be
more ahead in your career you're
probably going to be so that yourself is
more attractive but it's i think i think
that like men
i don't know i'm not really attracted to
50 year olds like i think i can be like
i'm not physically attracted to them i
mean mark ruffalo
i would call him daddy any day of the
week what's what's what's the oldest you
would
actually consider for a husband
uh
15 20
years old
no years older
no dislike no no no like i'm like i'm 25
so maybe 45. so you would consider a a
40-year-old guy seriously for marriage
and said yeah if you had no kids [ __ ]
most of them most of them probably have
children but like if you look good no
kids
sign me up
how about you
it would really depend because i know
some like men who are 50 who are really
they're running like iron man's
triathlons so so if they were like they
want to marry you start a life with you
you'd be open to that
do you know what i'm gonna be real
honest
i would i would be a gold digger if
there is an 80 year old man on his
deathbed who is like
i i would do it i would do it for that
easy life
there's there's there's no limit age
limit for you
i mean realistically yeah there is like
that's me just like
kind of like being realistically i'm
like oh [ __ ] i don't know because oh
there's a lot of [ __ ] to go in there
like even like health even like how open
are they to travel how committed are
they to their job how like no all those
things are there i'm just saying the age
what what's the age limit
i don't [ __ ] i don't know i don't
know she doesn't know i think i like i'm
trying to think the perfect age
i prefer guys my age but usually i think
like they're usually more like looking
for something casual yeah so that's why
i like guys in their mid-30s not because
i'm more attracted to them but just
because like
they're kind of like i don't know
they're not in like the casual yeah you
know it's weird like i
can get butchered out here if i say this
um i feel like for a mental thing i
prefer women who are older to actually
talk to on a
on a standard basis i'd say is
generalization
but then
if it's just casual fun then
to be honest it's kind of if she's
attractive
i have a heart take i think girls peek
at like 18
at the time
yeah
yeah rosemary says like 22-23 i think
personally for me
i would i would say and we're talking
general i would say 24-25 because that's
when i say she's still like if she was
hot at 22 she's not gonna not be hot at
24. do you know what i mean but she's
probably more mature and i value that i
think that 18 year olds look the best
because most girls gain weight
most girls don't gain weight in college
i know but they just look like most
girls get like beer bellies
in college i just think i just think
like because i'm at that age where girls
who hit on me are around that age yeah
and i find it weird because they just
look like children to me yeah
whereas i'm like now i want to i want a
woman yeah a young woman but i want a
woman you know what i mean like i feel
like i don't know that's what that's why
it's like
yeah i just yeah i couldn't i could like
i couldn't get a girl who looked
incredibly young looking i'd feel weird
i know some guys love that [ __ ] but
that's just i don't know i don't think i
think 18 year olds nowadays look like
they're 25. oh they did [ __ ] guys
okay
i'm like i see i'm like what the i don't
know
but
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't go lower than
23 though he wouldn't go lower than 23.
yeah
i remember the day that old guys got hot
it was really weird it was like i didn't
see guys i did it when i was 21 or 22. i
was going on dates with a guy that was
30 and i just couldn't get past it i was
like i can't he's so old
i remember like thinking like
oh he's 30 like that's so old and but
now i remember being like 24 i mean like
okay our 40 year olds attract our dad's
hot
yes oh my god it was a weird it was so
weird it didn't happen till like 24 23
maybe i was like oh this is strange this
is strange
i have a question for both of you is
there a diff well
what would you say is your
dating age range but then your sleeping
casual sexual age range
so for me i would personally happily
sleep with someone who was like 21 but i
wouldn't date someone who was 21. i
wouldn't like
yeah i kind of
i look for it all this like it's the
same to me
okay
like
i don't know seriously okay no not
seriously like yeah like oh like between
casual and serious
uh
i'd say casual
anywhere between
23 to like i mean i've dated a woman in
her late 40s before so i'd say like 23
to like 48. if we're talking seriously i
need to see what she looks like
i need
let me see they won't see they won't see
i won't show
if i wasn't going to be serious about
someone i definitely the younger they
are i'm like it doesn't matter i can
show you
let me see i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep the mic this way and i'm
just gonna hope that you why you still
got it for kit's sake i'm gonna oh is
that a
why you still got it why you still got
it excuse me
is that is that is that a thing don't
guys keep like albums of all the nudes
they have well if i if i end things with
a guy i have to i say to them i'm like
respectfully i would like you to delete
anything i've sent you but
[Applause]
i need you to delete this but i'm fully
aware that if i ever send something i'm
fully aware
i'm fully aware that if i send something
to someone that i'm and i don't advocate
for it at all but i'm aware that one
they're probably going to show some of
their male friends i know that i know
that's happened to me before that
they'll be like this is the girl i'm
sleeping with this thing i'm dating i'm
well aware that if i send something
that's it
uh it's it goes back to
consequences if i send a nude photo or a
promiscuous photo i am well aware that
it probably will not just stay
in his phone or with him and it probably
will not end
any comments on this
on what on the album
listen ladies
if you send a guy a nude photo it is on
his phone forever that's all i'm going
to say and i say this i say this in my
videos you guys you guys show each other
their girlfriend's nudes not their
girlfriends just like random hoes so
yeah so if they're okay so if there's a
girl that he's not taken seriously if
she sends him a nude he's showing it to
his closest i'll be honest he is but if
it's his girlfriend no [ __ ] way that
shit's his
no way and even if it was an ex because
it's like
yeah it's it's a respect thing isn't it
it's a respect thing
what about girls because they get dick
pics all the time what do you guys do
with that nothing personally i literally
can't [ __ ] stop it i'm like dog picks
over dick pics when people send me a
dick pic i do the fake like oh wow i
literally don't give a [ __ ] i don't
think i've ever gotten a dick pic not
like not like a one i asked for like
i've had yeah yeah yeah
but then have you have you ever felt the
need to ask someone no no no that's the
only thing i can keep that to yourself
and i say that i say my guy friends i'm
not i'm gonna be real with you if a girl
has ever i mean never say never but
again if we go back to
like majority and exception i think
majority of girls do not give a [ __ ] and
so if she's asking for a dick pic she's
probably just trying to inflate your ego
or act the way she wants you to act yeah
and same with threesomes though i know a
lot of girls who are like oh i've had
threesomes and oh wait let's have it oh
wow what the [ __ ] she looks good
[Music]
okay
um
with three i think more girls actually
like want to have threesomes than
admitted
just for the record that was not an
explicit pit that was a very yeah no
it's just a replace it was just it was
just a very beautiful face
but obviously that's nothing but yeah
yeah i think ah it's it's rough because
some girls want three students
statistically i know i know the stats
like most girls if they're like surveyed
on it like would do a threesome but
would they do it because they want to or
would they do it because i know most
women are attracted to other women oh
100 oh
i would rather have a threesome
yeah oh 100 and it's like really it
really grinds my gears especially on
tick tock when girls are like
oh girl crush or buy panic or i'm
straight i'm straight i'm like you're
not you're quit you're attracted to her
it's actually internalized homophobia to
be like oh i won't go that far i'm
uncomfortable being attracted to a woman
don't be you're attracted to a woman it
is what it is i mean i think there's
like levels there's like being like
things like that nurse joined pokemon
when i was like six i think there's like
things
i think they're thinking they're
attractive and like wanting to sleep
with them or like two years yeah yeah
yeah yeah i have a question why why
is it that if a guy's buy
a girl is less likely to do
because if it goes by guys like because
i can't why why is there a double
standard there okay i don't know i don't
know any guys who are buying the chat
you're welcome i don't know but when i
when i heard harry josie slept with that
that like nikita dragon whatever
it ruined it for me
i i don't know i like i can't tell you
why i just did
he was just like i couldn't i thought he
was attractive before and then after
that so the guy takes one it's a
feminine i think this guy takes one
eggplant in the bum
yeah
it's a great it's a wrap for him
why is that a thing is there something
you want to tell us
guys
no it's oh my gosh in my industry it'd
be so much easier if i was it's so much
easier no i think it's i think it's like
feminine like that's more feminine
we're like is it is it though
yeah no no and the other thing i'm
saying is coming which comedian said
this right this this
comedian from manchester but he was like
having sex with uh
girls whatever that's soft it's nice
it's warm getting taken dick is hard
that's hard that makes you more that's
[ __ ] harder than having said i don't
know why i can't explain it i i can't i
don't
okay on this same wavelength
i feel a bit weird about i feel a bit
weird about guys who are like insistent
on anal sex i'm a bit like
and there's that quote in is it forget
is it for getting sarah marshall which
is like if there's a playground
why are you why are you wanting to have
fun why are you wanting to have fun in
the stewardship why do you guys want to
play it i don't get it i get that oh i
get it i don't get it either
i i'm in agreement
i don't get it either way guys like hey
can we do that and i'm like why would
you want
that it makes no sense to me it makes i
agree i am like you maybe i'm like maybe
you're a little i get that i get that
it's tight but i'm like maybe you're a
little bit gay like maybe like and then
men are like no no no
maybe like a couple of my friends a
couple of my friends who have died
they're like oh it just feels better and
i'm like how i'm like you have to get
lube and everything so trying to youtube
friendly i just don't
the other thing has natural yeah i don't
know i don't get it but i am i am very
obviously because a lot of people in my
circles are of the you know lgbt
but it's pretty unanimous that women if
they're dating men they they if he's bi
or he's if he's had experience with guys
she's like no it just turns her off
completely yeah yeah yeah
i don't know why that's something i
tried asking for you but they couldn't
explain themselves i can't explain it it
just
ruins it
i'm funny with you i've slept with one
guy that i know wait aren't you pants
it
this is why i'm saying i sat with one
guy
um
with the knowledge that he was bisexual
and i was like
when he told me i was a bit like i don't
know why i'm a bit like
about it but then being pansexual
i mean women are like okay with it like
but men [ __ ] love it men and i think
it's that whole idea of that's the
amount of men this past year who have
been like well you have a threesome and
another girl and i'm like
i'll tell you now i'll have a threesome
with you another girl if you're both
like all about me but i would rather
have a threesome with like two women
wait women i had a question for you
do you like it if a girl's bi
are you into it
yeah sure okay would you be into it for
a wife
if she was bi yeah
yeah my first girlfriend who was mother
jesus she was bi okay
why oh i was just wondering if it was a
different do you think i'll say no i i
thought you might i don't know i'll be
honest right i don't give a [ __ ] what
anyone says
as long as i'm the only dick in her life
she could do what she wants
so she could
she'd be cool with her like dating
another girl yeah huh you know what she
that other girl probably be doing me a
favor in some
areas like if she wants to go shopping
and everything and she wants someone to
accompany her you know what babe take
your girlfriend man we were on the same
we were on this what do you think i was
talking about
oh my gosh
that that shit's all that [ __ ] is all
mine
but again similar wavelength is it
guys
that's what i really thought you meant
they'd like be like oh so she's going to
satisfy her but so
straight men particularly if you see two
girls getting off or lesbians you're
like love that [ __ ] and i asked my
friends i was like what is it and
they're like women are great you've got
double a good thing it's a great thing i
was like oh that makes sense but then if
you are straight women oh you see two
gay men getting off it's not the same
it's not the same i don't see too many
gay men getting off and i'm like what
they're really really attractive
it still wouldn't do anything for me so
it's a weird like
you know i'm like oh i don't and i think
that's a lot of even women sexually
objectify women
of course 80 of consumer buying
decisions are made by women
so so if women complain
about being sexualized in the media i'm
like ladies the media is for us
it's literally for us so it's like it's
funny because we complain about our own
doing
because if they're marketing
they're marketing like like women like
hot girls too
a hundred percent i know a lot of i know
a lot of straight women and i'll say
that i'm like you're not straight you're
definitely queer but they'll watch porn
with their partners and be like
oh i'm looking at the woman i'm not
looking at the man and i'm like yes
you're not
i i feel like a guy on this podcast
because like i recruit women for it and
i want them to be hot so i can like make
money off of you guys so like
so i feel like
i feel like a man because i'm like oh
she's hot let me let me go talk to her
you want to come on my podcast
that is that it's pretty privileged in
the halo effect it's so real and i
literally i'm here for it i mean if you
can make if you can make more from being
honest go for it i'll slide into girls
dms like come on my podcast i'll be
honest if i was a hot girl like giving
dating advice
you'd be making bank man i'll be making
so much more from that
right now
so much more i had a really good
question for you guys
no you're the host
ask me something ask you something yeah
what is
[Music]
okay what
is the worst
oh have you ever dated a crazy [ __ ]
uh we're going on a date like has
anything crazy ever happened to you
um i mean i've had i've had a girl yeah
the craziest thing it's not that bad
i've just had a girl like show up at my
house unannounced a few times and
saying that she left [ __ ] there and oh
she just wouldn't leave have you done
that
no i think my
i think um
i think one of my ex yes or no oh no no
no no no no okay
[Laughter]
the craziest thing is them trying to
trap me for a baby to be honest yeah i
think that's craziest thing
how did you know they were trying to
trap you
um
because she wasn't on any contraception
she was at that age
where
she was talking about these things and
she didn't want me to use protection and
she didn't want me to pull out
did she tell you that she wasn't on
contraception
yeah yeah
she like wrapped her legs around like
yeah she tried
she tried yeah um
and i was just like and i
i know are you dating her like in a
relationship or is it like
one was an actual ex of mine
but we'd broken up at this point
and another one was it was a casual
thing
but i noticed that she was like she was
just so she was just incredibly like
reckless and i was like why she was like
oh yeah i've only been this way for like
the past year or so
and i'm like
she was like yeah that's kind of when i
started getting broody i was like alarm
bells
i was like oh and
i'll be honest i just stopped seeing her
casually because i was like she's gonna
try and oh yeah that's not worth it and
i was like it's weird yeah yeah
it's mad
i don't know why
what would you guys say
is the num
what is the number one
trait that a guy
must have for you to even consider him
oh
oh [ __ ]
taller than the 511.
we stick with the height let's go
character oh character character i just
think it starts with like a physical
attraction yeah but let's say he's tall
okay
because you don't consider every guy
who's taller do you
no i mean not if i'm not attracted to
them but yeah it starts with height um
so
character yeah
that's literally i swear to god this is
what i go through i'm like i'm not your
dad but i feel like i should pick your
husband
i actually legit know
i'm like this is like the things i go
through in my head or doesn't care he
could be a political okay i'll i'll give
him more juicy one for the fellas
um
what is what is too small that you would
write him off completely
too small like yeah
what's too small i
like
it doesn't matter how tall he is how
much money he makes how cute how good
looking he is if he's this small i don't
really care i don't care about that
no i don't think as i've said i've said
that i don't think so like i think your
values is more important than sex i like
so i can that's fine
we're talking about like would size
impact
i am more likely to end something with
some of their too big
i am more likely to end something with
someone and so i've had a lot of guys be
like i'm big and i'm like i am
medically tighter than average and it
hurts it hurts so when a guy comes up to
me like big dick energy i'm like oh
that's a real turn off
i might be like i prefer medium to small
genuinely genuinely and i'm like and i'm
going to be real i'm going to be real
with men and i'm like none of y'all make
me finish so i'm like for me sex is very
mediocre
and as long as a guy could be micro
penis bb but be willing to use a toy on
me and i'd be like
actually no that's i'm lying to myself
micro penis i'd be like no but i've had
a lot i guess maybe migra i mean i don't
even know what that would i don't even
know what that would look like to be
honest
but as long as they were willing to
use their hands use their mouth use a
toy like as long as they were willing to
do what they could then i'd be like do
you know what because sex for me has
always been like
whether you're big whether you're small
whether i'm like i'm one of us is gonna
finish it's not gonna be me so i'm like
yeah yeah
literally it's been very disappointing
it's been very disappointing okay
so size doesn't really matter it's not
the size of the tool it's what you do
with it
yeah yeah how do you what are you
what am i
no no what are you showing me
oh god
like a meme or something like what
so i was going to ask you this tomorrow
on my show but i'll ask you now okay i
might ask you again okay so you said you
used to hate men you used to think like
men of trash and [ __ ] yeah yeah what
brought you out of that brought me out
of that yeah
uh i'm gonna ask you this tomorrow so
appreciating my best friend my balance
you give tomorrow has to be as good as
the one today um well i really didn't
hate man for that long it was a very
short period of time um but
i would say appreciating my brothers and
my dad
um so the men in your life yeah like how
could i say that men are trash when i
have like really really great brothers
and really great a really great dad do
you think if you came from a household
where it was only women
that that phase would have lasted longer
um i would say my upbringing has helped
me a lot in life i would say i'm
actually quite
like nuts in a normal way yeah but it's
only normal because like i could totally
see myself if i was like in a different
family like being a completely different
way yeah yeah you know what i mean
how much of how much of your character
do you think is your upbringing how much
of it do you think it's who you are
like it was always going to be i'd say
50 50.
um yeah i don't know that's a good
question i'd have to think about it more
but off the top of my head 50 50. have
you ever thought all men were trash
no never never and even even so that's
amazing for nowadays in this world in
this world and like so yeah my dad and
they say that well freud you've got
biopsychosocial got a lot of things but
i've got good brothers but i've got a
select few male friends that even if
and i do believe in like emotional
availability and i do believe kind of
that you attract energy
dependent upon like how you're feeling
about yourself and all that stuff but
i've got a couple of male friends
platonic male friends that i'm like
you if all the men in the world treat
you like [ __ ] i still wouldn't say all
men are trash because i've got a couple
of male friends i'm like you are a very
good individual
but then why don't you marry them
because because i'm not like in love
with them
well well i had a male friend that was
like that and uh unfortunately it they
did not end very well and um
yeah
uh
there's a couple of male friends i'm
like you
give me faith that there are good men
out there and there'll be a good man
that i'm attracted to and that is
attracted to me um
but then i admittedly i'm like i think
they're good men because of the female
influence in their life rather than
their father being like i'm going to
raise you to be a good man i think it's
more their mother being like i'm going
to raise you
to show you how we treat and respect
women so it's an interesting yeah
let me caveat about that because i kind
of agree and disagree i
i
think
i think only fathers can raise men
and i think only mothers can raise women
and i think a big part of that is
because
men and women have different
take different places in life
and i think i'll be honest i think i
don't
i don't know how a man can
be
the kind of strong leader masculine man
without a figure that is that and
the mother could be that i guess but she
usually isn't if she's chosen a man do
you understand what i'm saying like i i
kind of struggle
because kind of like you said like the
elements that make the bad man or the
traits that make him dangerous are the
exact things that make him very
attractive
and if a woman is gonna essentially
raise a boy
to not be those things that could
potentially be dangerous then by default
it means he probably won't be attractive
to many women
i feel
i think that i think i think there's a
level of emotional awareness that will
work that will help but i think
fundamentally fundamentally i'm not i
don't know i agree with you that makes a
lot of sense i think there's like well
there's a difference between like
masculine and feminine energies and
there's that balance but then that goes
into why a lot of people aren't
supportive of same-sex couples adopting
because they're like
you know
two men can't raise a woman
is that a valid concern
have you ever
they definitely would have read this you
ever read the superior man no
so even in homosexual relationships
there is still one who has a predominant
masculine core and one who have a more
feminine core which is why it works so
it has nothing really to do with gender
so in that sense
if
as long as you have a masculine feminine
yeah as long as you have that polarity
they can raise kids the same i think but
i didn't but then
i think
it's there are some things because
gender does play a part like a man like
those men will never know what it's like
to be a woman
so i think it would be harder for them
to raise a daughter i mean i think
there's like i'm not saying they
shouldn't be able to adopt i'm just
saying i i think there's genuine
concerns like that you could have i
understand i think there would like be
valid points so here's my question would
you
would you say it's more concerning for a
child to be raised in a homosexual
household or to be raised in a
single-parent household
i mean definitely the homosexual over a
single parent for sure as in you think
that's better that's better yeah
because at least there's like
some stupid likes to build like i think
it's worse for kids when they see
partners coming in and out of parents
lives so if it's a single mom like
they're gonna have a bunch of like
different guys in and out yeah you know
i think that's kind of hard on a kid
yeah
i i can't even imagine
and so would you sooner advocate for
that than for single-parent households
yeah
i mean i'm not i'm not saying like again
i'm not against
adoption for gay couples i'm just saying
like
i don't think
it's crazy to say that that could be a
concern
i understand why some people
it could be a concern do you think do
you think part of that concern is
because it's not really been done
this is the first time like anything for
sure yeah like you know we can't you
know when they wanted to go to the moon
i'm sure a lot of people were concerned
but that's because it's never been done
going into space do you know what i mean
yeah i agree i see both sides yeah i
could see it
do you think race plays a part do you
think
oh this is this is if we're going
controversial do you think it's
what do you think about a
white couple
adopting
an asian baby
i don't care
they love the kid
yeah i don't care do you think it's do
you think it'd be better for that baby
if they're with an asian
parent
or do you think it doesn't make a
difference
um
i mean they'll put you on this one no
i'm saying i mean i'm sure like the only
difference i could see is potentially
like questions would probably get
annoying over time and people always
asking if that's your parents and you
know stuff like that
but overall i mean if they love the kid
because i think this is this is a big
reason why at least from people i've
talked to why a lot of black women are
prefer
to
settle down with
another black man because
if it was anyone else especially if it
was a white man that like they will
never understand
and that
because they'll never understand they
wouldn't do you know what i mean
i don't know i'm just
i'm just playing devil advocate to
everyone's opinions boy
i do love it
what do you think
um well paramount is obviously if that
car if that child needs care and is
being cared for that's paramount but
then you've got the whole can you unders
like
it's the whole difference between
sympathy and empathy we can sympathize
with racial struggles but you can't
empathize because you've never been with
it and obviously if someone being
adopted into
a racial minority or their own race
they're going to get a more
accurate empathic experience
um
but then white families adopting racial
minorities those white families are
maybe potentially going to be able to
provide more because of the experience
provided to them in their white
privilege so it's really like
oh it's really messy like in an ideal
world i would love for people to be
adopted
within like their own
community i just think if the birth
parents are fine with it and the if the
birth parents are fine with who they
give the kid to yeah
and
the like why stop them yeah if the birth
parents are cool with it like why stop
them another controversial question okay
what would it take for your child to do
for you to disown them
um
sex don't say be left with don't say be
a liberal no no no no no um no no no no
um
no i would not mime and my sister is no
yeah so um
i would say
to disown them
any sexual act against the kid
yeah
you're dead to me i'll never talk to you
i think you should die if you touch a
kid
that's right yeah death penalty i stand
on this do you believe in the death
penalty for
people that touch children yeah just in
general
because in general
anything that's if you murder a kid
touch a kid yeah i believe that the
death penalty is
in full effect like i wouldn't even no
questions okay yeah all right how about
you
um yeah and i agree with that point um
like i want like anything like rape or
like sexual like
murder you know what i'm gonna be like
because sometimes people murder people
in self defense or within good reason
like there have been murder cases where
yeah someone will murder someone because
you've touched a kid and i'd be like
i don't condone it but i can understand
it but i'd love to categorically say my
moral compass is xyz but if you're a
parent you are willing to overlook a lot
of [ __ ] or you're willing to be like
do you know what i still see the good in
there more xyz so i wouldn't no but yeah
if they did any like rape i'd be like i
literally
if i was a parent i'd be like i did not
raise you this way so you've
disrespected me and you've hurt me and
therefore go [ __ ] yourself yes yeah
anything about a kid um
like
oh yeah those are the two that i'd 100 i
very like yeah like you've never seen
100 but those are the two that i'd be
like no in doing that
like you [ __ ] me over and therefore
i'm not going to care about you if you
didn't care about me like
i've got another one
okay
we all
you
may not we all enjoy hip-hop and rap
music
and we celebrate the artists
and we know full well that a lot of
these artists have killed people
yet we celebrate them
why is it if a lot of these artists have
killed people we don't say anything
but then chris brown
assaults rihanna and the whole world
loses their [ __ ]
um which isn't obviously okay but i'm
just playing
i'm more of a country fan i know i have
my rap reactions those are just to be
funny
um i'm more of a country type of girl
but
um i think it's like the gynocentric
social order because like it's almost
like they see rappers as like going to
war in a way
because they really don't like mess with
like normal people like normally it's
just like people that are involved in
that stuff yeah not making it right but
it's almost like seen as like like a
battle or like war of like between these
two where like rihanna is a girl
and i think it's like gynocentric social
order
yeah go on i was just going to say do we
think it would be different if it wasn't
rihanna it was just like some random
woman no i think it oh i think i think
it'd be the same i'll be honest i think
it'll be the same
yeah i think so too i think it'd be the
same
i don't think it's because she's rihanna
i think it's because
she's a woman okay so arguably so we
know that
the rapper the baby you might not know
who he is do you know bob and brother
you know who he is i don't know what
happened with him but i know who he is
so
apparently he's apparently deleted some
people
off of you know he's killed some people
um no one said [ __ ]
and then he made a homophobic comment
everyone lost their mind why is that
well culture
okay yeah
oh yeah i think there's a lot of um like
even separating like art from the artist
a lot of biases as to what you'll accept
from one person and not accept from one
person
and um
i think i also think a lot of people are
hypocrites i think a lot of people are
very quick to they say like those in
glass houses shouldn't throw stones i
think a lot of people are very quick to
be like
especially in uk culture i know so many
people especially as kids would use gay
as a slur in the playground but then
they literally will act as though they
never did and it's like
but ah it's oh there's so many
intersections of this of like power
privilege race like there's so many
intersections but i think a lot of
people are glory hunters i think a lot
of people will say things and do things
to be woke or better than and i'm like
yeah but i don't know enough about like
the actual situation to be like oh but
it depends on who he killed like if he
killed a [ __ ] like
white woman that was doing all this
charity work then they'd be up raw yeah
if he's killing someone who is
considered or who's it
that's why yeah no who's in i would say
it's because they're involved in that
life and it's kind of a choice like it's
kind of it's weird like
it's almost seen as like different live
by the sword die by the sword yeah yeah
i don't get it i'm like i would choose a
different hobby i don't know
i would
um
uh
you think of one a question yeah
um you can make it as
hard as you like hard as i'd like yeah
um
[Music]
do you think that
oh have you ever given a girl dating
advice
and it got led her astray
that it was like completely wrong advice
yeah
or or have you ever had a client that
you just thought was like bad [ __ ] crazy
you're like i can't there's no advice i
can give to you to help you because it's
just
because it's just who you are
uh
no one's it no one's ever lost course
uh no i've never per se
no i've never i've never thought
anyone's lost cause i've never given
advice where it's gone right no no if
it's gonna rise usually because they
didn't take my advice
do you think most girls listen to your
advice
uh if they're paying me
yes
if they're just asking me
because i have a lot of female friends
which is fine because that's what i'm
there for and i enjoy talking about it i
mean you know
um but i do have one or two
that they keep coming to me
and
i've been telling the same thing for
like six to 12 months
and then it's just got to a point i'm
like you have to stop paying me because
i'm just saying the same thing over and
over at this point yeah do you know what
i mean
um no i haven't actually
not yet
have you ever given guys advice no
you've never given guys advice not
really
no one because they don't ask actually i
have one guy that requested me for a
one-on-one but and i did do it for him
but it was more like
i didn't even really know what he wanted
to talk about he's just like 50 bucks
half hour your time i was like okay okay
i have a question you have a son
what are three things you would teach
them about women
i'd be like one i know they're pretty
but
be careful son
no i want something specific uh wear a
condom
[Music]
okay don't get the wrong [ __ ] pregnant
i swear to god you come home pregnant
i'm not helping you
um
don't believe her if she's on birth
control i don't care how nice she is you
never know
that's true um
but that goes back to it is it her
responsibility to his responsibility
i would say it's mostly hers because
again no woman can carry a child that
she does not take to term
um but don't give her that power son
don't don't give her that power um two
i would say
look for a girl that has the same values
as you
that's really important um three
pay attention to how attention seeking
she is
especially and pay attention to
how she acts around your friends when
you're not around
how are you gonna see how she asks
around your friends you ask your friends
yeah
yeah have your friend flirt with her a
little bit see what she does so throw a
little test away
yeah how often do girls do that a lot
they throw a test to their friend's
boyfriend oh no not
oh
wait
wait wait what was the alarm
um let me think so the
but
i
haven't heard too many people do like a
loyalty test to their boyfriends
i meant like i've seen a lot of girls
flirt with like guys when their
boyfriends aren't around that's what i
meant
you wait you've seen a lot of girls
flirt with guys uh-huh yeah like so say
um you guys are dating okay and you're
like
bye babe have fun
and then you leave then she starts
seeking attention from like another guy
and they're like
yeah yeah
so i've seen i've seen that a lot i see
that
a lot
is that because they're interested or
they just want attention
do you think i would say like 50 50.
yeah i mean i don't just see if they can
yeah i don't think some of them like
wouldn't actually do it
but
it's like
do you want a girl that's like acting
like that when you're not around and it
also it comes to um
emotional infidelity physical infidelity
and like there's the the big sort of
argument that a lot of people is like so
if you're a bar and you flirt with a man
for free drinks would your man be okay
with it or would he not and i know some
guys who are like yeah girl go for it
get me a free drink yeah i know some
guys especially but i know girls who
will be out with their man and a man
will float with them and they'll be like
yeah like
get me a drink get me two drinks and
then they'll literally take it and be
like this is for me my boyfriend and the
boyfriend will be there like
you're welcome but then i know other men
and i had a man i'd literally be like
leave me the [ __ ] alone i don't care how
good you're making me feel i'd be like
no thank you
no no no like oh it makes me feel really
uncomfortable but i know there are some
women who are very comfortable doing it
and some men who are comfortable with
women doing it and i'm like that is
confusing i would say
i would say if she is doing it where it
is an asset to him
fair game because i've had it where like
a girl got free [ __ ] and she's like i've
got this from this guy was hitting on me
i thought i should i thought you'd like
like this i was like all right i'll take
it
actually i have a question for you going
in have you ever taken back a cheater
no never
i wouldn't i'd forgive them
but yeah if they cheated me it's a wrap
but i think it's different for guys
i think it's different
i know a lot of guys have taken back
cheaters
really why do you think they took them
back i think they could do better
so they took them back because of
scarcity
probably
i don't know why else you would well you
so yeah
i i literally can't think of another
reason you if you thought you could do
better like
like that's it's like um
yeah scarcity
yeah yeah i think it's because it's like
i think it's hard to find people you
actually like you have to go through a
lot of like people till you find one you
like
yeah
like in general
you said you said the other day you like
you like you're not that fun of people
i'm not that full of people fond of
people
didn't you say that the other day
did i no i love people i'm like i'm a
chit-chatter oh yeah you are yeah i'm a
i just i'm i'm i said i'm picky with who
i date
oh maybe that's what it was for sure
like yeah yeah like like i wouldn't date
someone liberal but i'm like friends
like all my friends
like yeah liberals are fun
they're big fall pawns
come on you can come out come up with a
controversial
question i'm trying to think of one now
i'm trying to
because i've got a lot of unpopular
opinions but they're not really related
to like dating and sex but then i'm also
that's it i'm opinionated but
non-judgmental so i'm very like happy
everyone i'm trying to think
[Music]
i really want to bring one about like
family
um
you have a sister right
do you have any siblings yeah
so yeah okay you have a husband
right been married for five years
you find out he's been sleeping with
your sister
who do you feel most betrayed by
i would probably say my sister i'd
probably send my sister sister
who do you feel most people i think i'd
hate both of them like so much that i
would just never talk to either of them
[Music]
i can't even pick
i like i can't i can't panic then but
what if you're the rest of your family
were like no come on you need to forgive
them it brings the family i would then
cut out the rest of my family i'd then
be like no [ __ ] you i wouldn't i would
just say look it's me or her he can have
one of us at family outings and i would
pick the one who didn't sleep with the
relatives
that's who i would pick but you know
what
if my family went like no come on like
girls it's been like three years like
you're tearing the family apart i'd be
like crazy because i still don't have a
husband yeah
i feel like that sounds like a you
problem that she caused by sleeping with
my husband
and so if they couldn't see my i'd be
like okay bye like
no i oh no i'd feel more portrayed by me
but then i think that again is probably
just
a predisposition that the idea that
blood is thicker than water
when actually it's like you can't choose
your family but you can choose your
husband so it's oh that's that's real
tough that's real tough
okay guys
i think i think i'm gonna end the show
we're done yeah i think we're done i'm
gonna ask you guys one final question
okay good for
you
okay okay
f mary kell
okay
okay okay um
margot robbie
that's my female celebrity um jessica
alba
okay
or
uh rihanna in her prime
matter what do you mean no with the baby
bug
uh i would marry riri
oh
i love jessica nad i mean margaret
robbie though come one i'd have to
bang her and kill jessica and marry
rihanna
okay you're you're pansexual
i am all right so rihanna
no no i'm going to add another
i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna add in a dude um rihanna
um
michael b jordan
and
a margot robbie
i would marry michael b jordan he just
gives me so much safe energy and i'm
like this book oh
love him okay
i would
oh
i don't really subscribe to like
celebrity culture so i'm like
between
margot robbie and rihanna who would i
find more like
i don't know like but they're both
they're both physically attractive
they're both they're both physically
attractive and i'm like
margaret do you know what i'd probably
[ __ ] rihanna and then kill margot robbie
because i think
i think margot robbie is so hot
she's physically she's physically really
hot but i think we've actually been like
kind of sold the narrative that she's
like really fun like we used to be with
like jennifer lawrence but i'm like
rihanna is very sassy it's like that
whole like
do my tits offend you and i'm like this
girl does not like she's she's just hot
like mentally and like she's uh she's
mentally hot i feel like i feel like
margot robbie is arguably the most
aesthetically beautiful
woman like one of the most
i don't think she's the sexiest
yeah yeah like i think have you i think
jlo
is
sexy yeah she is like she's got a curve
she's womanly like margo's like margo's
like amazing she's incredibly talented
but she's like she's like aesthetically
gifted yeah do you know what i mean yeah
whereas i don't know like she just
doesn't have that level of
female prowess i don't know
huh and maybe that comes with age
maybe that comes with age
okay guys if i had to pick yeah what
would you choose well i don't know oh
wait shall i give you one let me give
you okay
okay um
okay
um
i'm trying i'm on my obscure one so here
[Music]
okay all right fine
do you need that
okay
pass
um
okay yeah
joe rogan
okay oh donald trump
[Music]
okay i think i would
is donald trump single in this is he his
age still it's him but he's single
okay um
okay
i probably
married joe rogan because i just think
we could like podcast together yeah
that's true i really f donald trump
because i think like i feel like donald
trump helps out the girls he f's you
know what i mean on the side like i
think he he would just be a really good
like person to be a side chick for
because i think he would like help you
out if you needed something like he just
seems like uh i mean there'll be a train
but i think if i like wanted a
connection somewhere like i think he
would hook me up yeah i just i feel like
he would you know now you got to do
something for me yeah i'm sure i'm sure
like i just you know but i'm doing that
anyway because it's f right absolutely
and kill johnny dab and i think those
are very good answers
yeah
thank you i thought you would have
married donald trump you know
i thought you would have married him
i thought that power and stuff would
have he's that hot
yeah is joe rogan hot
he's hotter than trump to me
okay guys this was a fun show thanks for
coming on
thank you for having us um go ahead tell
them where they can find you
um so i'm amy you can find me on
instagram at amy r duffy
a-m-y-r-d-u-f-y or tick-tock amy and
beyond
hello my name is kit once again kit
underscore is underscore me for
instagram and stay slick with kit on
youtube
okay guys you already know the deal one
buy the meal plan stop being chubby stop
being overweight get yourself a meal
plan and get in shape the link is in the
description
also do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell if
you've watched two or more of my lives
then you don't subscribe like this is
getting ridiculous we got beef okay
beef
it's like
it's just tiring yeah it's like i'm
giving you this content for what
for what you can't even hit the
subscribe button like
come on
we've got 100 super chat earlier yes i
don't know who your name is but shout
out to oh my god yeah you like me but i
love you for supporting me yeah you're
the stream you are my favorite super
chat i feel like you need to every time
he gives you a super chat now you have
to call him daddy
cause he's just he's